welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast I'm Greg and I'm Lindsay and we
have another great show for you today
but first Lindsay what's on your mind
I think I want to start today with a
book recommendation
um I read quite a bit and I'm kind of
hoping that if I give book
recommendations on the podcast maybe
other people will give me book
recommendations as well so the book that
I just finished is called the fifth
season it's the first book in a Trilogy
called broken Earth
um I'm on the second book now it's a
science fantasy genre which I guess is
like a mixture between Science Fiction
and Fantasy but there are elements that
remind me of post-apocalyptic novels as
well which I also love but it takes
place on a super continent where every
few centuries the inhabitants endure
what they call a fifth season which is
like catastrophic climate change brought
on by earthquakes and the main
characters have the ability to control
energy particularly being able to cause
or prevent earthquakes which you know
cause the catastrophic Seasons but
because of the immense power that those
people have in their abilities
everyone's scared of them and they're
like an extremely oppressed class of
people
but the the books were written by n.k
jemisin who's a black woman and I think
her perspective and the themes that she
brings in are just really refreshing for
those genres you don't see a lot of
people of color and women and Science
Fiction and Fantasy
um and so the books are filled with
people of different races and
sexualities and gender identities and
casts alongside with like these Magical
elements of people having these cool
abilities
um
all three books in the series won the
Hugo award uh and the author was the
first person to win the Hugo award three
years in a row or for all three books in
a Trilogy oh wow which is really
impressive yeah that's why like when I
learned about that I was like oh I Gotta
Give these a shot and uh As A Song of
Ice and Fire girly it's very comforting
to have a series that I love that I know
is completed and in fact will be
completed has it has been completed I I
yes who knows with Song of Ice and Fire
it's not happening absolutely no I mean
I've I've been uh skeptical that it
would finish for a while now but like
I'm starting to get skeptical that even
Winds of Winter will get done like
I think I think he's lost his drive just
doesn't have the fire in his belly
anymore
yeah I mean it's relatable the
procrastination he has so much else on
his plate but it is a bummer that we're
never gonna see yeah our dream of spring
yeah well I'm glad you're liking the
fifth season uh series you you
absolutely devoured the first book Is
the is the second one as good thus far
yes definitely I'm already like I think
a third of the way through and it was
easier I think to kind of just like jump
into the second book after finishing the
first one like the first one it actually
took me like a little bit to kind of get
into like when you are reading something
that is kind of set in a whole other
world you do kind of have to sink into
it a little bit and learn like what's
what the rules are of this world like
the characters it can take a little bit
longer to kind of
familiarize yourself with all of that
but now that I'm in the world like I'm
just going through the second one super
quickly nice yeah what about you what is
your recommendation today
um I have I have a video game
recommendation which
um I think video games are are like
books for boys uh basically no I'm I'm
just kidding uh that's a joke
I mean
I do think that there's probably a bit
of a bit of a split in terms of like
who's uh primary like recreational
activity to wind down is reading versus
video games that maybe breaks down along
lines of sex and gender who knows
um but yeah that's a joke it is a video
game which which is which is for girls
which is a video game for girls and boys
okay great
um yeah I've been playing track Mania
recently which has been very fun like
it's a it's a racing game
and uh long time listeners of the
podcast know that I previously used to
play a lot of Mario maker
and I think this scratch is a very
similar itch like
I am not someone who wants to have to
remember like 50 different things a
character can do and like the the
gameplay itself is like super complex I
prefer games with very simple mechanics
that reward like precision and high
level Mastery of those simple mechanics
um so yeah like like basic Mario very
simple like you run you jump that's
about it yeah but then like once you're
getting into doing like crazy shell
tricks and whatnot you are still just
like running jumping releasing shells
that's it like you're doing six things
total but like the the skill barrier for
like being able to complete hard levels
is very very high yeah even though the
mechanics are simple I think racing
games are similar like you turn left you
turn right gas break that's it
um but to get a really good time you
need like really clean lines you need
really good timing like it's uh yeah
like it's it's a very different game but
like it scratches that scene yeah you're
trying to like put together a perfect
run yeah yeah like easy to learn
difficult to master I I think that's my
sweet spot so I've yeah I've really been
enjoying that is it similar to Mario
maker in that it has the user made
content as well
yeah so um
there is there's a lot more developer
made content than there was in Mario
maker like there was like a um like a
story mode in Mario Maker that was very
short and extremely easy
um with trackmania the developers
release a new set of 25 Maps every
season so it's currently the summer
campaign
um but then also like the community
makes a lot of maps
um so yeah there is more like developer
made content and there's not like as
endless of a supply of user made content
as there is for Mario maker like I think
they're like literally tens or hundreds
of millions of Mario Maker levels it's
it's insane yeah I think it's more like
tens to hundreds of thousands of track
Mania tracks that are that are online
which it's more than I'll ever play
um but it is like
yeah like most of the content is user
made but it's not like
as much of a mountain of content but
yeah it's it's very fun and yeah I've
I've been liking it are there
leaderboards are you on any leaderboards
um there are uh so
it does it by like
by like country region and then like
globally as well and like I mean I've
been playing it for about a month yeah
I'm not like super good yet but I'm
right around top 100 in North Carolina
which
I don't know if that sounds impressive
or not but I'll tell you that it's not
because uh trackmania is a lot more
popular in Europe than North America
um but I I think like I think that there
are
close to like I think there are a number
of players in the hundreds of thousands
globally I think I'm like right around
top 20K in the world which for having
having been playing for a month like I'm
I'm not too displeased with that yeah I
would say nice yeah
um all right let's let's get into it uh
we got some plugs yeah yeah uh if you're
enjoying the show please like rate and
subscribe and tell your friends it
really helps us out if you're interested
in hiring a virtual coach to help you
with your training and or nutrition
Stronger by science has a team of
excellent coaches that can help you you
can learn more at strongerbyscience.com
coaching if you want to purchase
supplements from a reliable source and
support the podcast at the same time buy
from bulksupplements.com and use the
code SPS pod to get a five percent
discount and other than supporting our
team of coaches the main product that
Greg and I focus on these days is our
app macro factor it's a premium macro
tracking and diet coaching app we both
use it and love it and 85 000 other
people do you can try it for free for 14
days by using the code SBS during sign
up it's available on the App Store in
Google Play and if you want to learn
more about all the features in the app
you can check out our website
macrofactorapp.com
absolutely and if you'd like to stay up
to date with all of the research going
on that is related to Fitness Nutrition
getting stronger getting more muscular
Etc
um check out the mass research review
that stands for monthly applications in
strength sport you can check that out at
massresearchreview.com
um if you'd like to stay up to date uh
with the research going on in a way that
is cost free you can sign up to the
stronger by science newsletter we'll
give you free a free study breakdown uh
every other week straight to your inbox
we don't spam you like a lot of
newsletters do like it's not 20
informative content and 80 marketing
emails or anything like that but yeah so
if if you're if you're jonesing for
content on podcast off weeks that's when
our little research Spotlight
newsletters go out you can check that
out at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter that will also be in the show
notes if you'd like to stay up to date
with just other things in the stronger
by science extended Universe discuss the
podcast give us feedback Etc check out
our Facebook group and subreddit it's
Stronger by science community on
Facebook and reddit.com R Stronger by
science and finally if you have
questions that you'd like us to answer
on the show
um just in general it would behoove you
to join the Facebook group and subreddit
because if we're soliciting questions
about a particular topic that is where
we'll kind of post The Prompt but
otherwise if you just have general
questions which will be answering one of
those at the end of this podcast episode
uh yeah send those questions to podcast
strongerbyscience.com record a voice
clip around 30 seconds a minute tops and
and email it to podcast Stronger by
science dot com and if we like your
question we will answer it on the show
I think that's about it so so let's get
into it
um
so uh we are doing a bit of a series on
micronutrients
um and I'll just say from the jump I am
like slightly apprehensive that no one's
actually going to listen to this series
because
for uh as we'll talk about in this
episode like micronutrients are one of
those things that are important but I
think a lot of people
I think very few people have like that
strong of opinions about micronutrients
it's not it's not a topic that gets
people really fired up I think it's
something where
folks know it's important and it's just
kind of filed away in the back of their
mind like oh yeah like micronutrients
are good uh eat some fruits and
vegetables like that's fine I don't need
to know anything else about it
um so yeah like I don't know if this
will be the biggest hit series in in
podcasts in Stronger by science podcast
history but I I think it's there is a
lot of surprisingly interesting and cool
content on the topic that
um I mean further reasons I just
discussed I suspect a lot of people
aren't aware of because this just isn't
a topic that gets that much attention
um so before we get into it just just on
a pure Vibes level lens
um
if if someone such as myself were to ask
you what are some of the things that
come to mind just when you think about
micronutrients
um like what what are some of those
things yeah I think similar to you like
it wasn't something that I put a ton of
thought into until recently
um but
if you were to ask me this I don't know
a couple months ago a year ago or
something like I would say oh it's like
it's the good stuff that's in fruits and
vegetables like a lot of
um
plant-based foods will have like a lot
of vitamins and minerals those are
micronutrients those are good for you
maybe like stuff in a multivitamin or
something like supplements you might
take
um I know that like
an association I had was was kind of
like the people who obsessively track
certain micronutrients and that wasn't
something that I ever did or like quite
understood like why people were so
interested in it
um but I agree with you that like now
that I've learned more about
micronutrients which we'll get into why
that is in a second I do think there's
some really interesting stuff there's
some fun facts and I think this series
will be good so if you're listening
already if if we got over the hump of
getting you to click on this hopefully
you'll enjoy it and uh
you'll agree with us yeah stick around
there's there's a lot of uh there's a
lot of fun stuff coming down the pipe
yeah so Greg why are you doing a series
on micronutrients in the first place
yeah so so two things uh the first
reason I'll just be completely
transparent about this
um macro factor or nutrition app
recently launched a full Suite of
micronutrient tracking features
um and so in in some way uh talking
about micronutrients on the podcast does
like double a little bit as marketing
content but that's not the primary
reason
um so we launched those micronutrient
features so I had to uh read a lot about
micronutrients and make a lot of
micronutrient content for the macro
Factor website and the macro Factor
knowledge base
um and I'll I'll tell I'll tell you guys
a little secret about the podcast I
double up a lot
um I've got a lot of stuff going on and
uh I don't have have a ton of time to
research stuff and write about stuff
in one com like in one domain and then
come up with completely separate content
for the podcast like there just aren't
enough hours in the day yeah and since I
put a lot of time and effort into
learning more about micronutrients and
making micronutrient content that's what
you're getting for the podcast because I
just don't have time to to uh just make
net new content that that isn't going
anywhere else
um so yeah just being transparent about
that on the front end but then second
and I think more importantly is
um I I do think micronutrients are
pretty poorly understood by people who
are into health and fitness yeah
um there's just not that much content
about them that's being put out and the
content that is put out is kind of
boring it often is or like alarmist or
fear-mongery or it feels like it's
usually kind of in the realm of like
super food adjacent stuff like yeah and
I'm just like I don't know if I can
trust this yeah for sure yeah um but
yeah like there's a ton of content out
there on like calories and macros and
micros are like I said before just kind
of hand waved away
um there will be a mention maybe of oh
yeah like micronutrients are important
so eat your fruits and veggies sometimes
and that's about it yeah
um but like you like you alluded to
before like there is like the content
that does get put out is often kind of
bad uh either because it's like
excessively focusing on nutrient
deficiencies or which I mean I'll just
say up front a lot of people listening
to this there's like a non-trivial
chance that you do have like
insufficient intake of some nutrient or
another uh probably a very low chance
that you actually have a true nutrient
deficiency like that that is a term that
I think is very overused
um which we'll talk about in part two of
this series
yes unintentional teaser but um but yeah
and uh yeah there's a lot of like
fear-mongering I guess
[Music]
um
and uh yeah I I don't know like there's
a lot of stuff about like this one
nutrient is super important and if you
don't if you don't get enough of it like
all of this bad [__] will happen yeah it
feels like
why I've been kind of hesitant to ever
look into it for myself or track it for
myself as it feels like it's just going
to be a lot of things to freak out about
and I you know I've gotten this far in
my life without feeling like you know
some some terrible Health consequence
from not having enough of a vitamin or
minerals so I'm like well you know
I don't know yeah for sure I mean that
that's absolutely absolutely valid and
understandable
um yeah there's also I think a lot of a
lot of content of people like like you
said like uh kind of super food
discourse yeah like people picking a
single micronutrient and treating it as
if it's a wonder drug so some some
examples of that in recent years
um is like maybe five years ago or so
vitamin D was very hot
um like there were a lot of influencers
saying like ah everyone's deficient in
vitamin D you need to like Mega dose
vitamin D that's gonna prevent cancer
prevent osteoporosis uh prevent all of
these like autoimmune conditions like
blah blah blah whatever and it was
mostly mostly claims that were quite
poorly supported but
um yeah people talking as if like
vitamin D was a wonder drug yeah
um go back about maybe like three or
four years before that and you saw a
similar thing with Omega-3s like oh this
is like so big for brain health so big
for heart health
um yeah like like no one's getting in
enough Omega-3s and like if you do it's
going to turn you into a [__]
ubermensch basically
um and then going back even further than
that like this this is something that
there are still Echoes of today where
people might take like a mega dose of
vitamin C if they feel like they're
getting sick but talk to talk to your
parents or depending on your age people
who might be like in their 40s or 50s I
would say uh yeah like like people
between their 40s and 60s would probably
be kind of the Prime ages for this but
vitamin C like it used to be so hot back
in the day due to this guy named Linus
Pauline who was of the opinion that like
like aging itself and most health
problems were the result of excessive
oxidative stress and so if you took high
doses of antioxidants in general and
vitamin C specifically that would be
kind of like the Elixir to Good Health a
long life preventing a ton of diseases
and like most of those claims also
didn't pan out yeah
um yeah they're there has been through
the years a lot of micronutrient content
that is basically like that here's this
one micronutrient it's basically a
wonder drug
um and yeah like most of that stuff just
hasn't panned out but that that is I
think a context a lot of people have in
mind when they think about
micronutrients
um and so yeah like I wanted to do this
series just to provide you The Listener
with uh basic information so that when
you encounter claims about
micronutrients in general or specific
micronutrients you'll have you'll be on
more solid grounding you'll have a a
more robust base of understanding to be
able to understand and critically
evaluate claims
um and also there are a lot of fun facts
and and fun little pieces of historical
trivia about micronutrients uh that
you're probably not aware of even if
you're a pretty big nutrition nerd so
they're I think it's just a fun topic
and I think you will enjoy it yeah well
let's get into it before we get too
ahead of ourselves though uh what are
micronutrients in the first place can
you give us just kind of like a working
definition
um sure yeah so I I couldn't find like a
single definition that everyone agreed
to but
um I mean the the basic understanding is
kind of contained in the word itself
micro so you don't need to consume too
much of it and nutrients uh something
that that nourishes you
um so yeah that's like the basic idea
but I think there's a difference between
the explicit denotation of the word and
like the connotation of the word kind of
how people how people use it just in
day-to-day life and I think when people
talk about micronutrients they're
essentially using it as a shorthand for
everything you might want to track
related to your diet
um besides yeah
yeah
so it's more of a category by exclusion
where it's like if it's not calories or
macros ad those are micros
um I think maybe a more appropriate term
for what people refer to as
micronutrients would just be like
non-energetic essential nutrients
because that's what they are
um because yeah like not all of them are
that micro so for instance fiber
um like people sometimes lump fiber in
with micronutrients especially like the
iifym crowd yeah and
um yeah I mean like a lot of people
consume 20 30 40 grams of fiber a day
like that's yeah kind of a lot you know
um or sugar I guess yeah yeah uh I think
yeah like that that I guess does fall
under the definition of like not
calories or well no it's amazing like
it's a carb yeah yeah yeah
um
um yeah so things people consider
micronutrients not all of them are that
micro like fiber for instance
um and there are also other compounds
that you could definitely consider
nutrients which are just things that Aid
in in growth and development and health
that you do consume in relatively small
quantities but that are non-essential so
things like phytonutrients for instance
or something like creatine like those
are nutrients you consume in small
quantities but they're they're
non-essential so typically they wouldn't
be considered micronutrients but yeah uh
long story short it is kind of a hazy
definition I guess
um
but yeah so I I wanted to First address
some some basic information about
micronutrients or non-energetic
essential nutrients and then dig into
some questions and controversies with
plenty of fun facts along the way so
very first thing when I say essential
nutrient
what I'm talking about is a nutrient
that is necessary for uh depending on
what definition you look at people will
say either normal development and good
health or normal development and normal
function
so normal development basically from
from fetus to adulthood like stuff you
need to consume to make sure you you
reach like full adult height uh without
um like like mental deficiencies like a
lot of micronutrient deficiencies can
cause issues with like mental
development normal skeletal development
Etc so you know that's the normal
development part and then the second
part is either good health or normal
function like those are the two terms
you'll see thrown around which as we'll
talk about uh in a bit are kind of
nebulous terms but those are the terms
that you see thrown out and the third
part of the definition is that there are
things that are necessary for normal
development and good health or normal
function that must be consumed from
dietary sources so there are a lot of
biomolecules that are absolutely
critical and necessary for normal
development and good health that your
body produces itself an essential
nutrient is something that the body
either doesn't produce at all like
vitamin C for instance or something that
maybe it does produce but not inadequate
quantities for what we Define to be
normal development and good health or
normal function so an example of that is
niacin like vitamin B3 if memory serves
uh but yeah like your your body produces
some niacin but nutrition researchers
and epidemiologists look into it and
they're like yeah like you produce some
niacin but not enough for what we
consider to be good health so you also
need to get some from your diet
um and that seems straightforward but
like I mentioned before it is a
surprisingly hazy definition so here are
a couple examples of
uh how how this kind of understanding of
essential nutrients uh is is like sort
of hazy around the edges
so vitamin D for instance
definitely considered a vitamin
considered an essential nutrient
Lindsay would it shock you to learn that
vitamin D isn't an essential nutrient
for most people or for for at least a
lot of people well that's what I was
thinking about when you were saying the
thing about like it's something that
needs to be consumed from dietary
sources yeah because vitamin D is a
thing that you get from the Sun from
being outside yeah yeah like your your
skin can well there are multiple stages
of vitamin D synthesis that include your
skin your kidneys I think your liver
like there's the the precursors of
vitamin D kind of peeing all around
um but yeah like the the rate limiting
step for endogenous synthesis is
primarily just sun exposure like that's
uh what kind of converts precursors of
vitamin D to vitamin D3 which like if
you take a vitamin D supplement it is
probably a D3 supplement and then
vitamin D3 is what uh other tissues
convert to like the bioactive like the
most bioactive form of vitamin D
um but yeah like like a lot of people
just don't have to worry about vitamin D
intake at all if they consumed no
dietary vitamin D they'd be totally fine
because if you live at latitudes that
are close enough to the equator and
you're outside enough your body
synthesizes enough vitamin D but
uh you know I I realize that I'm
speaking to a primarily American and
European audience if you get to high
enough latitudes it is an essential
nutrient because for at least parts of
the year uh you're you're not getting
direct enough sunlight to get enough UV
rays to actually cause that conversion
to vitamin D3 in your skin so then it
does become an essential nutrient that
you do need to get from your diet
um but yeah like the the just
considering it an essential nutrient it
is essential for some people it's it's
completely non-essential for others just
because like they do get enough sunlight
and it's fine
um and it could be different at
different times of the year too yeah for
the same person for sure yeah
um
another example is creatine for instance
just as a recent pod topic yeah yeah
just as a nutrient that could be
considered an essential or uh
potentially conditionally essential
nutrient that isn't on any of the
official lists but it could be yeah um
so it is something your body can
synthesize
um but maybe it doesn't always uh
synthesize it in sufficient quantities
for and this is where the nebulous
definition of good health or normal
function comes in like what does that
mean
um so for instance low creatine intake
is associated with a nearly two-fold
higher prevalence of depression so in a
study using inhanes data the people in
the lowest quartile of dietary creatine
intake had a prevalence of depression
symptoms of like a little over 10
percent and people in the highest
quartile of creatine intake had a
prevalence of depression of a little
under six percent so like almost a
twofold difference between people with
lowest and highest creatine intake
um and it's it goes beyond just kind of
mere associations
um because you know you could look at
that and there could be any number of
other like explanatory factors or biases
or whatever to explain that finding
Beyond a causal relationship but there
is also like experimental and
mechanistic research where they take
people with either like clinical
depression or like subclinical
depressive symptoms and supplement them
with either creatine or a placebo and
creatine supplementation does seem to
improve depressive symptoms in a lot of
those studies
um
and so yeah I mean but it's a question
of like
does normal function include like oh you
have good mental health right yeah yeah
yeah so yeah it kind of gets to that
idea of well how do we Define normal
function how do we Define good health
like that is that is a kind of a Sticky
Wicket uh as it were yeah I don't know
if that's correct slaying there I am
I've never heard that before you you
always have new phrases it it just feels
fun rolling off the tongue yeah
um but yeah so like there there is a
case that could be made that creatine
might be an essential nutrient might be
a conditionally essential nutrient
um but yeah since the definition is kind
of hazy like who who knows maybe it is
maybe it's not
um
all of which is to say like this stuff
is kind of fuzzy and the nutrient
categories themselves as I've alluded to
before do already allow for some of that
fuzziness so nutrients are considered
essential or non-essential but then
there's a third bucket of conditionally
essential and
um
those are nutrients that are essential
for normal health and function
um but most people uh like produce
enough on their own and it's fine so
um yeah like uh I think probably the
best example of that that a lot of
people listening to this podcast would
be aware of is conditionally essential
amino acids like there are essential
amino acids they're non-essential amino
acids and then the conditionally
essential amino acids are amino acids
that are that are essential like you
need them for good health and function
but they're considered conditionally
essential as dietary nutrients because
most people under most circumstances if
they don't consume enough from their
diet it's fine they can just synthesize
them from other amino acids but with
certain diseases if you're taking
certain medication if you're
particularly young if you're
particularly old you might not be able
to synthesize those uh conditionally
essential amino acids endogenously and
high enough quantities so then they
become essential so they're considered
conditionally essential
um yeah so so that is a whole category
yeah whole another bucket but it's
sometimes a judgment call regarding what
should be considered essential versus
conditionally essential versus
non-essential
um it's like those two examples I gave
before vitamin D and creatine you could
you could easily make a case that
vitamin D should be considered a
conditionally essential nutrient because
if you live close enough to the equator
and you're outside sometimes like you
you don't you don't need to consume it
it's fine
um but if you live further north or
further south than that you do so
essential for some people not for others
that seems to meet my general
understanding of what conditionally
essential would mean but it's always
just considered an essential nutrient
like any official Source you look at and
then on the flip side like
creatine for instance could be I think
considered a conditionally essential
nutrient
um it seems like most people with low
creatine intake are fine like I
mentioned before people with low
creatine intake do have a higher
prevalence of depression but it's still
in the neighborhood of ten percent yeah
they're not all depressed yeah it seems
like 90 of people who have low creatine
intake are fine
um but when those people are given
supplemental creatine their symptoms
improve which suggests that maybe it is
like it is an essential dietary nutrient
for those folks again like that seems to
meet my understanding of what
conditionally essential would mean
um but yeah all of which is to say like
we as humans I think like categorizing
things like this is essential this is
not this is maybe in the middle yeah um
but there aren't bright lines between
those categories there there are just a
lot of judgment calls with everything
related to micronutrients and one thing
in a category might not
like be the same as another thing in the
same category correct yeah yeah like
there are some that to be clear are like
absolutely essential like no questions
asked like uh the the first the first
two
um or the first two vitamins that were
discovered were vitamins B1 and B2
um
I I forget which one is which uh but
it's it's thiamin and riboflavin and if
you don't consume enough of one it
causes a condition called berry berry
and if you don't consume enough of the
other it causes a condition called uh
pelagra or polite or pellagra like I've
heard it pronounced both ways uh and
like that will kill you like if you if
you don't consume enough of those you
die right that's or or like [__]
vitamin C and scurvy you know
um so yeah like there there are some
that are clearly and obviously essential
and then there are there are some that
are like kind of on that easy border
yeah um but still considered essential
correct uh yeah and
like I've been saying this whole time a
lot of that haziness does just relate to
the idea of good health and and normal
function as criteria for determining
what is an essential nutrient or not
like those are kind of nebulous terms
um it's like a an example here is uh
there are a host of benefits from
consuming a lot of phytonutrients that
aren't considered vitamins so like
polyphenols for instance which you can
find in a lot of fruits or
isothiocyanates which you find in uh in
brassicas like broccoli cauliflower
brussels sprouts cabbage whatever
um like this isn't the episode to get
into it but like there there are a lot
of health benefits associated with
consuming those nutrients
um but they're not necessary to stay
alive so
they're not classically considered to be
micronutrients like you're not going to
find an official Health body that says
like
um oh a quercetin like that is an
essential nutrient for instance like
that that's a polyphenol
um but yeah like
it's but those are those are things that
you're typically going to be healthier
if you consume them yeah so then the
question is like how do we Define good
health or normal function like you
will you will be alive if you if you
don't consume any any of those other
phytonutrients like uh-huh you will
still stay alive and you will probably
live a pretty long time but like you
might have a higher risk of like cancer
or heart disease or whatever it might be
just like sickler in general yeah and so
it's it's a question of like well
you're Pro you're probably less healthy
than you would be if you did consume
these things yeah but how are we
defining good health how are we defining
normal function
um and yeah so it is just like kind of
hazy and nebulous so kind of the
takeaway from this intro I guess is just
that like a lot of like a lot of things
related to micronutrients are a little
hazier and more nuanced than I think
most people would expect and I'm
wondering if that surprises you no
okay
um
interesting could you expand on that or
or like if you have nothing to expand on
that's fine but
just I'm wondering why you don't find
that surprising
well I think you phrased it in a way I
do find it surprising that this stuff is
hazy I do not find it surprising that
people don't expect it to be hazy oh
okay yeah yeah
um Okay so
why why do you find it surprising that
it that it is hazy
what you were talking about whenever you
hear about
things that kind of have their own
categories and like we you know it felt
like a scientific Pursuit which you we
have the tendency to think like oh well
they have just kind of sorted all this
out and it's very cut and dry it's very
black and white
um they have everything categorized in
the way that it needs to be and I just
have to like follow the recommendations
for the categories yeah
yeah no I I fully agree like I was in
the exact same place and
um I I think that I think that does
relate to a dynamic that we see pretty
frequently that that
I think I pretty frequently call out but
just it Hannah occurred to me to look
into it more when it comes to
micronutrients and that is that like
a lot of
messaging for the purpose of Public
Health is like intentionally made like
super simple and stripped of nuance
because like most people don't care that
much about a lot of this stuff yeah and
so if they're going to actually like
consume recommendations and
understand them well enough to try to
follow them like they need to be pretty
simple and like there is a difference
between recommendations made by a public
health body and the clarity of the
research underpinning those
recommendations right like a lot of
times and I I think
I think that this I think I I think this
is something that makes people like go
slightly insane when they learn it for
the first time and just go and like
really conspiratorial directions
um they're it's it is not infrequent
that a situation arises where there is
something that that people know or or
very very strongly expect uh to be very
important for public health like you
know if if people follow some
recommendation like they they anticipate
that it will save thousands tens of
thousands maybe hundreds of thousands of
lives but uh the research underpinning
the recommendations isn't like as strong
and as clear as you would probably want
or expect it to be but you're put in a
position where you're trying to make the
best
decisions and the best recommendations
possible under considerable uncertainty
um
and so like like for instance
I I think I think like a good example of
this is like all of the people who just
assumed that like every nutrition
researcher was in the tank when
um it like had been balled off by uh
like like
green companies or like Monsanto or
whatever when more research started
coming out suggesting that like uh High
saturated fat intake like probably is
still kind of bad but like maybe not as
bad as we've been telling you for the
last few decades but the thing is like
the research from the last few decades
did like pretty strongly suggest that
like high saturated fat intake did was
definitely associated with and probably
caused heart disease but it wasn't like
the magnitude of the effect wasn't super
clear kind of the the cutoffs of how
much saturated fat you had to consume
before risk started going up wasn't
entirely clear
um and so like if if you go back and
look at what the state of the research
was in the 80s like it was just much
worse than it is today and so like yeah
they they made the best recommendations
they could under the uncertainty that
existed at the time that they were
making the recommendations and then uh
more research comes out stuff changes
and and when I think when people find
out that oh man these things that were
presented to us by our doctor or by the
government as just a single number or
single Target to aim for uh without any
complexity like you you assume that it's
really really robustly strongly
supported and then when things change
you look into it a little bit more or
you come across an influencer talking
about it and they they reveal that like
ooh this wasn't that strongly supported
yeah like what's going on yeah it's like
that that's just a standard thing in
like public health [__] like that is
something you have to do all the time
um but yeah like
micronutrients were a topic that
I I wasn't that invested in so so I just
looked at the recommendations like I was
like oh they're they're giving a single
number to aim for like there has to be a
reason yeah there has to be a ton of
research for them to be like so
confident to distill this recommendation
down to a single number and then when I
started looking into it I was like oh
yeah like just like everything else in
nutrition this is way hazier than I
expected it to be I don't know why I had
any other expectation but I did so yeah
I think just like when you put a
specific number on something it makes it
seem much more concrete than it actually
is I I agree a single number without
like a uh
confidence band yeah which and we'll get
into this in episode two as well there
is a confidence band on these nutrient
recommendations yeah and no one knows
about never heard of her like people
people just talk about the RDA but
that's like that is implied by like a
distribution of like assumed needs and
yeah yeah folks just aren't and that
would be so helpful for people to know
because like
yeah you can you can succeed without
hitting this number right on the head
yeah like and so yeah if if things were
presented as more of a range I think
that would have clued me into oh yeah
okay like [__] everything else in
biology this shit's this shit's hazy uh
things vary from person to person but
since it is typically communicated to
people as a number if you if you see a
single number without a confidence band
around it you assume that that's a super
precise number yep and oftentimes it
isn't yeah
um I think we can get into categories
yeah let's do it so there are several
categories of micronutrients and
essential nutrients vitamins minerals
essential fatty acids essential amino
acids and choline fiber and water in
their own individual categories of one
uh so why don't you kick it off by
talking a bit about vitamins sure thing
so vitamins are organic molecules and as
organic molecules they're composed of
the elements you would expect any
organic compound to be composed of so
carbon nitrogen oxygen hydrogen and
sometimes like other little things here
and there like vitamin vitamin B12 has
some Cobalt in it but uh yeah there are
they're organic compounds yeah something
on a carbon backbone which is functional
group stuck to it normal [__]
um and you don't just find them floating
around in nature so at some point in the
food chain they had to be synthesized by
some other living organism that either
you consume directly or you consume the
thing that consumed it
um so vitamins by and large are made by
Plankton bacteria plants or other
animals that either we consume directly
or we eat the things that ate them yes
and vitamins are subdivided into two
broad categories there are the water
soluble vitamins and the fat soluble
vitamins water soluble vitamins you have
uh I I'm just going to give like the B
vitamin numbers instead of the names but
you have okay B1 B2 B3 B5 where's B4
maybe we'll talk about that in a second
uh B7 B9 B12 and vitamin C
um and the all of them have two
commonalities one is that water soluble
vitamins are easily absorbed and easily
excreted
so most of the time that like if if a
nutrient accumulates in your body it's
often because it's fat soluble like it
is soluble in fat so it can be kind of
stored in fatty tissues it just kind of
finds a home there
um whereas water soluble stuff it can
it's like coming in coming out yeah I
can more easily go in and out of cells
can more easily be excreted because it
it's it's happy just chilling in your
blood and then can be filtered by your
kidneys
um and it's easily absorbed because you
have a bunch of water in your mouth you
have a bunch of water in your stomach
you have a bunch of water in your
intestines like it it dissolves easily
and then can be absorbed right away easy
peasy
um so that's one commonality easily
absorbed uh readily excreted
um and so like as a result of that you
generally don't have to worry about over
consumption quite as much like there are
there are issues that can arise from
over consuming water-soluble vitamins
but it's a bit harder to achieve those
things
um without specifically like mega dosing
some particular vitamin so uh like
vitamin C for instance like you're
you're not going to to have an excess
consumption of vitamin C from just like
eating oranges or whatever but if you
take like a vitamin C supplement that
Mega doses it maybe you could and most
of the time the
kind of resulting negative effects of
over-consuming water soluble vitamins
are pretty mild and transitory so like
vitamin C is another good instance of
this if you over consume vitamin C like
it causes a little bit of nausea you
might vomit you might have diarrhea and
that vitamin C is out of your system
within 24 hours as long as you don't
over consume it the next day like you're
fine yeah the exception like the pretty
major exception there is vitamin B6
which if you consume really really high
doses of vitamin B6 it can cause like
neuropathies like nerve problems that
are persistent like you damage the
nerves and they just kind of stay
damaged uh but yeah for the most part
yeah water-soluble vitamins easily
absorbed readily excreted yeah typically
not needing to consume needing to be too
concerned about over consuming yeah is
that just your body has an easier time
kind of flushing them out when it needs
to yeah because they can't accumulate in
fat right yeah
um so so that's one commonality the
second commonality is that all of them
the reason that they are considered
essential nutrients is their function as
either a co-enzyme or cofactor do you
know what those are lens
um I wouldn't be able to give you a
definition I don't think but my
understanding is like it is something
that is required for
like it's a it helps something else to
kind of like work in the way that it's
supposed to or be absorbed in the way
that it's supposed to yeah yeah that I
mean that that's
that that definitely puts you in the
right direction okay
um so like there are differences like
slight differences between coenzymes and
cofactors and it's not really worth
getting into them too much but
um essentially you a nutrient is a
coenzyme or cofactor
um
if like based on how it interacts with
enzymes so just kind of like biology 101
most of the chemical reactions going on
in your body don't really happen
spontaneously some of them do like for
instance creatine in your body some of
it will spontaneously degrade to
creatinine
um but most of the chemical reactions in
your body that are occurring at pretty
high rates are facilitated by enzymes so
those are little proteins that
um it's it's it's like the lock and key
concept that you may have learned in
like high school biology like a single
protein or multiple proteins or uh as
we'll talk about in a second uh
different carbohydrates like they link
up with an enzyme and whatever reaction
that needs to take place to things being
joined together two things being split
apart the enzyme is the thing that
facilitates that occurring and what a
coenzyme or cofactor does is uh it
basically facilitates that enzymatic
process so it could be the case that
it's like absolutely critical where you
have the enzyme you have the molecule
that it's supposed to build or break you
have both of those things together but
if you don't have the coenzyme to bind
onto the enzyme no reaction occurs like
that's one kind another kind is like it
could be a regulatory thing which like I
don't think that's the case with the
vitamins but it could be that like you
know maybe this particular enzyme can
cause this reaction at a rate of three
reactions per second but you you hook a
cofactor coenzyme up to it and now it
can do it at six reactions per second
and then kind of the Third Way that this
could work is it might be that like you
need to
ah like
um carboxylate a particular protein in
order for it to be able to do like don't
worry what any of these words mean you
might need to like carboxylate a
particular protein today another
reaction and you might have like a
coenzyme that is the like carboxyl group
donor where it needs to be present uh
with the enzyme and the thing it's going
to react with so that the enzyme can
like take the carboxyl group from the
coenzyme and hook it on to the other
thing so
um yeah like so it's not a thing in and
of itself but it is an essential
ingredient for other things to be able
to happen yeah yeah like I think that's
a good way of looking at it
um yeah like it there are things that
allow enzymes to do what they need to do
and enzymes doing what they need to do
is critically important right because
most of the reactions in your body are
facilitated by enzymes
um so yeah like that that is what the
water soluble vitamins do like they are
considered essential nutrients because
there are like important things related
to protein synthesis metabolism whatever
that need these coenzymes or cofactors
to do what they need to do
um and and if you don't consume these
vitamins in sufficient quantities those
critical reactions can't take place uh
and I I think that sometimes comes as a
surprise to people like that what the
water-soluble vitamins are for coenzymes
and cofactors because I think because
those are vitamins you hear about all
the time yeah so it's like you do think
about it they're doing something by
themselves like that they themselves are
doing something special for sure yeah
yeah
um and I mean of the water soluble
vitamins the ones that
people talk about the most by far are
vitamin C and uh and folate and maybe
like B12 like I I would potentially toss
that one in there and no no one talks
about them as cofactors really it's just
like oh like if you're pregnant you need
to take folate to memory serves like
help with neural development like maybe
help with the neural tube closing I
don't know I'm not a embryology guy
don't take that one to the bank but yeah
it's it's something that's important for
pregnant yes
um vitamin B12 I don't think people even
think about what it does but it's just
like oh like my Energy's low I'm gonna
go to the doctor and get a B12 shot yeah
make me energetic for reasons that I
have no idea how it works uh and vitamin
C like people think about that as an
antioxidant uh primarily because of of
Linus Pauline like a ninja before uh but
yeah like vitamin C is absolutely an
antioxidant and there are absolutely
other functions that some of these uh
water-soluble vitamins have but they are
considered essential due to their role
as as a coenzyme or a cofactor and so
like in vitamin C's case like it is a
strong indiscriminate antioxidant but
it's also a coenzyme for
um like some of the critical reactions
in collagen synthesis okay so if you
don't consume enough vitamin C like oh
yeah like maybe General levels of
oxidative stress will be a little bit
higher but you'll be much more concerned
about the fact that you're getting
scurvy and scurvy is a connective tissue
disorder like you you aren't consuming
enough vitamin C yeah and so like the
first sign is you start getting like
little little patekia around your skin
just like little
um they look like little spots where
just like capillaries have ruptured oh
yeah because like there is collagen in
the walls of capillaries to maintain
structural stability if you can't turn
it over and and synthesize enough little
capillaries will rupture you get patekia
for for like power lifters listening to
this if you've ever had like little
spots on your face after pulling a Max
down that's what I was just thinking
about yeah serious to get that all the
time yeah that's that's patekia like
your um your blood pressure gets in that
case it's your blood pressure getting
high enough that it like ruptures those
capillaries but uh but yeah but that's
what it looks like if if you're just
spontaneously getting that uh because
you're not consuming enough vitamin C
like that's kind of your first sign of
scurvy and then uh like your your
um like risk of joint injury starts
going up like like tendon tears ligament
Tears like other collagenous tissues
you're more likely to break a bone like
your bones get more brittle like the
strength of your bones comes from like
the calcium and the minerals and whatnot
uh the the bit of flexibility they have
comes from the collagen in your bones
like bones are discounting water I think
like 30 of the mass of Bones is collagen
um you start bleeding from your teeth
because it's not good yeah like you're
in trouble if you're bleeding from your
teeth yeah like there are collagenous
tissues that are like holding your teeth
into your mouth like not God and then
like eventually you die like it's scurvy
is nasty stuff and um yeah like that's
why vitamin C is an essential nutrient
like it's yeah it's antioxidant
functions who gives a [__] if you're not
able to synthesize collagen right and I
feel like you hear about vitamin C and
scurvy
but like I didn't know that it was
collagen yeah like I didn't know that
that was the thing that actually matters
and vitamin C is the thing that's just
helping you be able to continue making
collagen yeah like that that is what it
does that that is why it's an essential
nutrient
um okay so those are the water soluble
vitamins so many fun facts already
thank you great job I appreciate that I
think I think the most fun ones are yet
are yet to come maybe in this section it
may be in the fiber section I can't wait
uh so the fat soluble vitamins you have
vitamins a d e and k
um just a little fun fact to start with
uh vitamin like all of these aren't
single things
um what do you mean so like vitamin
like vitamin B1 for instance is thiamin
like there is a single molecule that is
thiamin and thiamin and B1 are the same
thing like identical
um vitamins a d e and K like it you
assume that it's like a singular thing
again because it's vitamin A not
vitamins a or vitamin A's or whatever
um yeah like are they things that are
like usually together uh it describes
like a class of compounds okay so
um
like Vitamin E for instance there's like
a whole class of compounds called
tocopherols and there's another whole
class of compounds called
tocotrienols never heard those words in
my life and there are multiple
tocopherols and multiple Toco trienols
that are collectively considered vitamin
E
um same thing with vitamin A like there
are three types of pre-formed vitamin A
there's retinol which I think is a lot
in a lot of like skin care products yes
uh there's retinoic acid
um and there's retinol which is like
retinol but the O at the end is isn't it
got it
um and then also uh a lot of carotenoids
are also considered vitamin A like a lot
of like nutrient labels report vitamin A
is like I forget the exact term but
basically like vitamin A equivalence so
um like beta-carotene for instance in
carrots is kind of like half of a
vitamin A molecule and if your body
needs vitamin A and there's
beta-carotene floating around it can
just link up a couple beta-carotenes and
now you have more vitamin A yeah
um so yeah like it describes like
multiple compounds but they're all just
when when we talk about them we just
talk about them as vitamin A or as
Vitamin E or whatever yeah this might be
a little bit too off topic but like why
are those things grouped together as
Vitamin A
[Music]
um
they're they're all kind of like in the
same lineage I guess okay
um
so like there are certain vitamin A
things that like retinol particularly
does and there are certainly there are
like certain vitamin A things that like
retinoic acid primarily does I don't
think retinal is used for quite as much
stuff but like yeah basically like some
stuff you use retinol some stuff you use
retinoic acid
um and like the the carotenoids
themselves are like antioxidants but
like for them to be uh to do vitamin A
stuff like they're converted to retinol
first
um but yeah like they come from kind of
the same lineage and like you can
interconvert between them and so it's
like you could say they're and a lot of
it is just from a sense of practicality
because you could say you need like
I don't know the the vitamin A RDA off
the top of my head but I think it's like
900 milligrams or micrograms one of the
two whatever it doesn't matter but yeah
you could say like oh you need
um you know 200 grams of retinoic acid
and or uh milligrams and 700 milligrams
of retinol but like it wouldn't matter
because like if you did just need more
retinol you could convert the retinoic
acid to it and vice versa so yeah I mean
that's okay that's why okay
um
and so yeah like they they all refer to
to classes of compounds instead of just
like one specific thing
and really they're
um they don't have many commonalities
behind that so they're typically a bit
trickier to absorb because unlike things
that are water soluble they're fat
soluble and you have a lot of water in
your mouth stomach and intestines you
don't have that much fat just floating
around in them so
um typically if you consume them and you
want to absorb them well it helps to
consume fat soluble vitamins with a meal
instead of on their own because like the
fat in the meal will help quite a bit
with absorption
and one General commonality that is not
always the case
um is that your body can accumulate fat
soluble vitamins in your body's tissues
like it can store them in fat
um and just kind of like release it over
time or whatever and
um so like for instance if you consume a
bunch of vitamin C like most of it's
going to be out of your system in a day
or two with vitamin D for instance
um
for people with really really low
blood vitamin D levels sometimes doctors
will prescribe very intermittent Mega
doses of Vitamin D just to get their
vitamin D levels on track which might be
like 50 000 IUS once a month or like
once every two months or something like
that
um because it's it's fat soluble so if
you you know give someone a shitload of
vitamin D like a ton their vitamin D
levels can still be elevated a month
later
um
and uh but that's not the case for all
of them like vitamin K for instance
doesn't accumulate in the body like it's
it's fat soluble but like it behave like
vitamin K behaves a lot like a
water-soluble vitamin like it's pretty
easy to absorb it doesn't bioaccumulate
in the body and uh it it is also like a
coenzyme
um helps with like the reason I I pulled
carboxylation a second ago is like it
helps with carboxylation of like a
particular step that's related to like
both bone formation and blood
coagulation
um yeah like it
it it is fat soluble but it behaves a
lot like a water-soluble vitamin whereas
like vitamin D is just it's a steroid
hormone like it's it's its own thing
like it has it's built on the same
cholesterol backbone like estrogen or
testosterone or cortisol or whatever
else would be
um it works like a steroid hormone like
it diffuses into a cell binds to a
vitamin D receptor that translocates to
the nucleus it affects gene expression
and unlike you know vitamin K or water
soluble vitamins that do one thing like
it's a it's again like some of the
water-soluble vitamins also antioxidants
but like essential because it does one
thing vitamin D does a shitload of stuff
because it's a steroid hormone like it
directly affects gene expression in like
most cell lines so
um yeah like the the fat soluble
vitamins are the Wild West like there
are there are four of them but beyond
the fact they're they're fat solid
valuable it's it's hard to pick out a
ton of commonalities between them beyond
that
um
so yeah those that that just kind of
gets your feet wet with vitamins but I
have some fun facts about vitamins okay
you want to hear them yeah okay so
first thing
have you ever wondered where the term
vitamin comes from or did that just kind
of Go Down Smooth and it's like I don't
need to know the etymology of that I I
don't care why they're called vitamins
yeah or that one yeah okay yeah that's
that's totally fair I'm I'm a weird
little freak when it comes to etymology
like I I love knowing where words come
from
um but vitamins
they're uh their name is a mashup and
also now kind of a misnomer so they were
originally called vitamins uh and that
coin was termed by Dr Casimir Funk who's
kind of like the father of vitamins and
um
it was a mashup of vital and amine vital
because you had to consume it and amine
because the first vitamins he discovered
were amine compounds like we talk about
like amino acids they're like it's a
particular like nitrogen containing
functional group that like determines if
something's in a mean or not so yeah
like the first vitamins he found were
amines that needed to be consumed to
prevent diseases uh berry berry and
pellegra and so uh yeah it was like
they're amines they're vital you have to
consume them bite amine like just fun
little mashup yeah
um and uh yeah so now like these days
plenty of the compounds that our
vitamins aren't amine kind of counts
like I mentioned vitamin D like it's a
steroid hormone like it's not an amine
but vitamin had already called on both
in general society and in the the
nutrition research Community
um so scientists just dropped the E from
the end and they're like ah well they're
not a means but we like this word it's a
word now yeah we'll just call it
vitamins I guess that's easier to
pronounce anyways it is but yeah so
that's where the term vitamin comes from
which I think is fun
um second when I was putting together
the micronutrient content I know I know
you asked me this question like these
names are crazy like where did it come
from like they're it's not uh just
concurrent so with the letters
themselves you have e c d e and then it
jumps to K why does it jump to K and for
the B vitamins we have one two three
five six nine twelve like where's um
um yeah so the the story behind those
things is relatively simple but I also
think kind of interesting first is
Vitamin K like why is it a straggler why
isn't it vitamin f and uh it's because
it was discovered by a Danish scientist
called Henrik Dom or Henrik Dam who
published his results in a German
language Journal uh like chemistry
biochemistry journal and vitamin K helps
with blood coagulation it also helps
with bone formation but what what Henrik
Dan like discovered was that it was like
a coenzyme for like one of the steps in
blood coagulation and that's that's why
one of the reasons it's essential and uh
coagulate in English is spelled with a c
but in both Danish and German it's
spelled with a K and so vitamin K was
originally called coagulations vitamin
and it was uh eventually just shortened
to vitamin K
and um yeah it just kind of stuck like
people people talked about it as Vitamin
K for long enough that when uh folks
kind of realize like oh man we're just
going through the alphabet otherwise and
it just jumps from E to k
um you're just like well whatever it's
it's been k for long enough
um and also as we'll get into in a
second with the B vitamins people
initially thought that there would be a
lot more vitamins than there turned out
to be
um so I I don't know if that's this is
the case but it wouldn't surprise me if
folks were like ah we've got vitamin A
we've got some bees we've got C we got
the like we'll we'll get to K eventually
it's like we can just stick with this as
Vitamin K and like we'll we'll fill in
the other ones
um I don't know if that's the case but
like it wouldn't surprise me right
um and yeah like just as another kind of
fun fact there like this this is a
random K in something related to science
due to Germany and there are still like
several holdovers of just like random
case showing up and stuff where you
would think they wouldn't belong due to
kind of the the Primacy of German
science in the early 20th century
so
um if if you need to look at the
electrical activity in your heart
typically these days in America that
will be called an ECG an
electrocardiogram but you will still see
like some doctors or like some hospitals
and like particularly like older
researchers sometimes still refer to it
as an EKG because like that was just the
general term up until like relatively
recently
um I still think of it as EKG I do too
like I grew up with with uh EKG yeah and
like the switch to ECG seems feels to me
like it's changed in the last like 10
years or so
um yeah like it's it's the same thing
like the EKG was invented in Germany and
uh in Germany electrocardiogram like the
cardio is spelled with a K which is why
it's an EKG
um yeah so that just that is where
vitamin K comes from and why it jumps
from E to K and then the missing B
vitamins
like where is vitamin B4 why where's
vitamin B8 or whatever
um
they used to be there there used to be
vitamin uh be one two three four five
six seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
um
up to 16 was pretty solid and then there
were uh sort of borderline pitches of
people trying to pitch up to Vitamin B
20 and then some that had like letter
subscripts where it's just like gosh
this is vitamin BK whatever uh but yeah
like people were trying to toss a ton of
B vitamins out there and up to B16 were
the ones that were considered solid
enough that they were kind of like
formally given those those numbers
um
and uh
yeah like so the background for that is
that after Casimir Funk discovered the
first vitamins in 1912. uh all of the
rest of the vitamins that we have were
discovered in the in the next 35 years
damn
um so there was a big push like in the
early 20th century to discover new
Vitamins because there was a lot of
excitement about vitamins potentially
curing diseases
um like maybe close to all diseases
depending who you talk to yeah
um so I lied before I said B1 and B2
before but it was B1 and B3 uh niacin B3
deficiency causes pelligra B1 deficiency
causes berry berry and like those were
the first two he found like uh there
were two discrete understood disease
States
where they were caused by not consuming
enough of this particular nutrient if
they consumed more of the nutrient it
stopped the disease
so boom like vitamin it's these little
things that like you don't consume them
you get disease you consume them it
cures disease and then
that would be exciting and then more
early research started coming out like
people had known
um since I think the 1700s that
consuming Citrus prevented scurvy right
but the Pirates uh duet pirates on ships
yes that's what I associated with you
scurvy dog yeah
um but yeah so they had known that
citrus fruits consuming citrus fruits
prevented scurvy but the actual compound
that prevented scurvy was discovered in
this era that being vitamin C
um so you know that's another disease
state that people were very well aware
of at the time uh and they already knew
how to treat it but it's like oh this is
caused by not consuming this one
nutrient consuming this one nutrient
prevents or cures it
um vitamin B was discovered around this
time and it prevented or cured rickets
which like we don't think about rickets
that much anymore mostly because people
found out about vitamin D and like now
they make sure that that little kids get
vitamin D but
um vitamin D is a condition of bone
malformation and like
rickets I mean is a condition of bone
malformation
um because like if you're not consuming
enough vitamin D like you can't absorb
calcium uh sufficiently and like
incorporated into bone
and Ricketts used to be really common uh
like especially in Europe and probably
even more people had like subclinical
rickets uh like back in the day people
were very very tiny like remember when
we when we went to Ireland and went to
that castle and they had the suit of
armor of the lord of the castle and it
it looked like a Halloween costume for a
seven-year-old yeah yeah crazy all the
door frames very short yeah people used
to be so tiny yeah
um looks like part of that was probably
just low total energy intake like
General malnutrition yes like
specifically uh uh like low vitamin D
intake and you're in Europe you're at
high enough latitudes that you're not
getting that much direct sunlight so
people just wound up shorter and if they
really really had low vitamin D intake
like maybe they weren't eating enough
eggs or like drinking enough milk like
those were the two things in their diet
that had some vitamin vitamin D in it
um yeah they would get full-blown
rickets which is like really serious
bone malformation you wind up very
stunted generally bow-legged
um like a lot of Orthopedic issues
throughout your generally quite short
life and uh so yeah that used to be so
common and then we discovered vitamin D
and found that hey you consume this
stuff you don't get rickets that was
[__] huge
um and so you can understand at this
time yeah why they were so hype about
this and why they were like oh my God
this is incredible like where we're
seeing all of these diseases that are
around us all the time that we unders
that we understand to be like pervasive
we had no idea how to prevent it before
and it turns out they're they're just
these little guys in food that when you
eat them you don't get these diseases
and we're we're discovering a lot of
instances of that so it it generated
this idea
that it it might be that most
non-communicable diseases are just the
result of vitamin deficiencies and like
now we look back at that and we're like
Ah that's crazy that's super reductive
but like for the time period you can see
why they would think yeah you know it
makes sense
um and so there was there was so much
enthusiasm about this line of research
yeah everyone wanted to discover new
Vitamins because like they're like dude
like we don't want people dying of like
all of this weird [__] that people died
of in Europe in like the early 20th
century
um so there was just kind of a gold rush
of people trying to discover new
vitamins and basically just people got
out over their skis a little bit
um so there were things that uh either
they thought were essential based on
some research that maybe was done poorly
or misinterpreted that turned out to be
non-essential or they would find
something that is like definitely a
critically essential molecule that you
can consume from your diet but then
further research found they're like oh
no like your body does produce that
insufficient quantity so like it
wouldn't be a vitamin like it wouldn't
be an essential nutrient because you do
endogen endogenously synthesize enough
of it
um and so yeah just over time there were
a lot of things that were initially
considered vitamins particularly B
vitamins in this initial Rush of like
just just Delirious excitement about
about vitamin research that better more
sober research over time just kind of
pruned the list back a little bit at a
time and they just never reordered it
like the the wind was out of their sales
yeah I think that's the I think that's
the big Miss like once you realize that
like vitamin B4 isn't a vitamin which uh
well we'll get to this in a second it
like it kind of is again
um vitamin B4 was choline they oh yeah
like they they considered it a B vitamin
and then they said I don't know like
your liver endogenously synthesizes it
it's non-essential we're going to prune
this along with the rest of them and
then like in the 80s and 90s they
started doing more research and realized
like oh you do endogenously synthesize
it but like
you probably do need to consume some
from your diet for good like Liver
Health in particular so like as of 1998
it's considered an essential nutrient
again but it's not they didn't they
didn't give it B4 status back
it's just its own thing now all right
but yeah so like there did used to be
like B4 B7 B8 whatever
um and yeah they just uh they just
didn't reorder them
so kind of lazy I I think they should
have
um yeah that's that is why it skips from
E to K and why there are missing numbers
in the B vitamins
so um
I I think that that does lend itself to
two just kind of like
brief little discussion topics okay one
is about sort of like
The History of Science and like the the
economic uh concerns related to science
and the other is just kind of the the
history of like one weird trick
approaches to Medicine
and so
um
yeah for for the first one
just as like kind of a note that maybe
we can talk about maybe we can Riff on
maybe there won't be much to talk about
we'll see but like with the with the
vitamin K and like that being a holdover
from from Germany thing
um I think a lot of people uh don't stop
to consider that like it is kind of hard
to disentangle science and economics
especially like basic Sciences like
trying to discover new nutrients like
kind of bench work
um
so like most of the things that have
German names that that uh stick around
to the modern day like vitamin K or like
EKG like things like that a lot of them
were discovered or developed before
World War II
um because basically before World War II
Germany was like the economic Powerhouse
of Europe and like it's it's getting
back to that status again but like
from kind of like the early to like uh
basically in like the post-napoleonic
period like Prussia and the area of
Europe that became Germany uh was just
like crushing it like it was the
Industrial Center of Europe and
science is expensive like
a lot of this [__] is not cheap yeah and
um like these days
America is the home of like a extremely
disproportionate amount of scientific
breakthroughs right and the other
countries where you see scientific
breakthroughs coming from you got like
Germany you got the UK
um you got you got China coming up the
ranks these days like sometimes Japan
sometimes South Korea but like generally
very prosperous societies and that's
because like I I think I think people
get like weird
I don't know like
like racial or like cultural supremacist
ideas like oh like these these are the
countries making these scientific
discoveries because this is where all of
like the best and brightest and smartest
people are I see and like that's true to
some extent because of brain drain
because a lot of the best and brightest
and smartest people are like hey I want
to do research so I want to go to a
place where we're doing a lot of
research funding
um
but by by and large it's just a question
of like what countries have excess money
to dump into research like I don't know
the number right off the top of my head
but like the the NIH and NSF like uh
National Institutes of Health and
National Science Foundation they're like
relative funding is below what it was
like pre-2008 but it's still like
billions and billions and billions of
dollars
um whereas like you know like I'm I'm
sure that there are like incredibly
smart people in Indonesia that could do
incredible research like if the
Indonesian government just had like a
spare 50 billion dollars laying around
like they'd probably invested in like
building schools and hospitals right
um so yeah like like pre-World War II
like Germany was destroyed in World War
II like we but between the Americans and
the Soviets like uh we firebombed it
back to the Middle Ages the Soviets uh
all coming from the East also like
[__] a lot of [__] up so like it it
took them a while to rebuild but before
that like they they were [__] rich
and so like a lot of science came from
Germany like pre-World War II and like
these days a lot of it comes from the US
and you know
rather than that being the result of
just like oh this is where like all of
the best and smartest people are it is
just more an economic thing like oh
that's that's where all of the money
used to be to just like dump into
science and now all of the money to or
like a shitload of money to dump into
Sciences like here or in China and like
yeah so that's when people when people
think about like the geograph like
geographic distribution of of uh like
epicenters of Science and where like
breakthroughs are happening
I don't think they think about that yeah
and I wonder how that affects
obviously like
nutrition research stuff like this where
you're trying to figure out nutrients
that are essential for humans on kind of
like a broad span like all humans this
is essential for and like we were
talking about with like vitamin D it's
going to depend where you live yeah and
how close you are to the Equator so if
you are having a lot of your research
done in these specific epicenters that
do not represent entire continents
what does that mean for these
recommendations that they're giving in
terms of like what is actually essential
when you're not representing like huge
swaths of humanity yeah I I think I
think that's a good point and honestly
I don't know
I don't know if we have the research to
know whether that's a problem or not
um it's like a good example is like in
Psychology research uh they've they've
had a reckoning in the last decade or so
um when it came to a lot of stuff
related to like behavior and like
personality types and and stuff that was
previously presented as like oh these
are just Universal facets of The Human
Condition uh they realize like oh wait
like most of our research just comes
from like
affluent college students at like the 10
top universities yeah um that were like
disproportionately white
disproportionately affluent
disproportionately well educated and so
there there's a term well there's an
acronym weird like most psychology
research subjects historically have been
weird which stands for
people who are white educated from
industrialized countries and I don't
remember what the r and d stand for but
yeah like yeah and that's something that
in that field has been recognized as a
potential problem potential blind spot
we need to redo a lot of This research
with different people from different
parts of the world different cultures
different socioeconomic backgrounds to
see if some of this stuff is as solid
and is as universal as was was
previously believed yeah with nutrition
research I I do think that the example
you brought up of vitamin D is a good
one like I I like I think that like if
the Hub of nutrition research globally
was like Nigeria I think like vitamin D
would be considered a conditionally
essential nutrient instead of essential
because yeah like for most of the people
doing research on vitamins like
yeah it's it's [__] Folks at like
Harvard or like in the UK and whatnot
like yeah in like Massachusetts or
London like vitamin D is absolutely an
essential nutrient because for a large
part of the year they're not getting
enough direct sunlight for your skin to
synthesize it but yeah if the research
was centered somewhere closer to the
Equator I do suspect it would probably
be considered conditionally essential
instead
um
I'm not sure though
if I'm not sure the extent to which like
nutrient needs differ from person to
person yeah
um like I mean like there there is
research on that like the as we'll talk
about in episode two kind of the range
like the the understood range of like
vitamin or mineral or essential nutrient
needs like it is understood that there's
quite a bit of variance from person to
person but like a lot of that research
is still based on
American or northern European
populations and I I do think it's not
inconceivable that people who live in
different parts of the world who have
maybe had like
have descended from people who for tens
of thousands of years have had very
different dietary patterns exactly their
variable could have been like some
genetic selection to select for people
like I don't know maybe maybe like your
ancestors going back 5 000 years just
like you didn't consume much
um
like soybeans or like the specific foods
that are like rich in choline it very
well could be that for you choline is
not an essential nutrient because like
your your people just produce enough
choline in their liver that it's fine
whereas maybe people who you know for
the last few thousand years have been
consuming more like choline-rich Foods
maybe there just hasn't been as much
like selection pressure for like high
levels of endogenous choline like yeah I
think that that's a possibility
um I think that would be
like I'm not confident that that is a
dynamic that would exist I don't think
there's enough research to know if it is
right and if it if it does I would
anticipate that it would primarily be
relevant for nutrients that are
in kind of that hazy Borderland between
essential or conditionally essential
like you know maybe well maybe creatine
maybe maybe well definitely vitamin D
maybe choline maybe niacin like like
some of those but like stuff stuff like
riboflavin or like folic acid like a lot
of what is universal definitely
essential yeah yeah yeah
um
but yeah so that that's the first thing
just it is it is difficult to to
disentangle science and economics
generally and a lot of what we perceive
to be as like cultural advantages in
science is just like oh this is the rich
country like it has billions of dollars
to dump into research uh the second
thing uh like I mentioned is
um like early vitamin research and
vitamin history does speak to the
history of like one weird trick
approaches or beliefs about medicine
um so that's basically the idea that
like there there is there is something
or like a small number of things where
like if we get this right we can prevent
most diseases cure most diseases like
everything's good
and so like I think we look back and
kind of scoff at folks in the I don't
know 16th 17th 18th centuries who
believed in balancing the humors to
prevent diseases uh you know like uh
you're you're too flammatic like that's
why whatever is happening
um but both both the
idea of like bloodletting to like cure
disease but also just the the general
idea like like how how simple were these
people that they thought that like this
one method of like balancing the humors
could fix everything from like a
toothache to impotence or whatever yeah
um but like I don't think we've gotten
too far past that uh it's kind of a
quirk of just how our minds like to work
yeah like it it's just like slightly
more sophisticated now and like
yeah there there are there are elements
of it that might be true so it's easier
to like give it a bit of a pass so
um yeah like like
the early Research into vitamins was was
a lot of it was animated by this idea
that like yeah we find vitamins we can
cure most non-communicable diseases
it'll be great well what I mean of
course if they did have a couple
situations in which that did happen yeah
the first couple that they found they
were like oh everyone that we find were
curing a new disease like let's [__]
go exactly and there's there's a large
space for Discovery like when you're
setting out you don't know how many
you're gonna find like it could be a
dozen it could be a thousand yeah you
know
um yeah that's heartbreaking yeah I feel
so bad for them well I mean as I'll talk
about in one second like there was an
example of that that happened in our
lifetimes
um so yeah like after after vitamins
kind of the next big one was Penicillin
um like it before people found out that
uh anti uh antibacterial like resistance
was a thing yeah uh or like drug
resistant bacteria dude penicillin
[__] rocked like it was a wonder drug
like it uh cure there were a bunch of
people dying like in terms of
communicable diseases you mostly have
bacterial infections and viral
infections
and early on like before drug resistance
kicked in penicillin did just knock the
socks off of most bacteria that could
infect humans yeah
um and yeah I mean that was like what
seven I think 17 years after
um after vitamins were discovered like
vitamins were 1912 I think penicillin
was 1928 1929.
um and then you know you fast forward a
few years
I I'd mentioned Linus Pauline before but
like there was there was an idea that
was like now we look back at it as a
fringe Theory but
um a lot of like serious people thought
that vitamin C was like legitimately a
wonder drug back in the day
um they didn't understand
like all of the nuances or hardly any of
the nuances of like redox biochemistry
and why just like indiscriminately
throwing a ton of antioxidants into your
body isn't actually a good thing won't
actually do all of the things that you
think it will do but yeah like people
did used to think that like most
kind of like what we now think of as
like serious diseases like back in the
day it was a lot of like communicable
diseases uh and a lot of the
non-communicable diseases like rickets
or pellegra or berry berry were like
nutrient deficiencies
um these days like we're we're pretty
good at treating a lot of communicable
diseases but the non-communicable
diseases that we're worried about like
heart disease cancer like a lot of
things along those lines
for various reasons a lot of very
serious folks thought that like mega
dosing vitamin C would would radically
reduce your risk of those things in in
significantly extend human lifespan
which is another kind of like one weird
trick type of thing
um and the example of something in our
lifetimes like people people don't
remember like how hyped people were
about this but the Human Genome Project
like it wasn't
the the dreams of the Human Genome
Project weren't quite like as unbridled
or as expansive as the dreams of like
the early vitamin researchers but I mean
in the 90s when it was going on like we
we just had a much
poorer grasp of like genetic regulation
like I think people kind of knew that
like epigenetics were a thing but yeah
like
[__] was still like very hazy
um just the the like genes themselves
are important but like
um gene expression is also very
important and that's like another huge
entire can of worms
um
because yeah like a lot of the early
stuff that was known about genetics
was also like pretty simple it's like
there there is a single Gene that if
there's a single like nucleotide
substitution either have normal blood
cells or you have sickle cell
um like very simple there was like a
single Gene that was like the calls of
Huntington's disease again like very
simple
and there was a lot of
uh excitement that that would be the
case for a lot of genes like we unravel
The genome and a lot of these
non-communicable diseases that that seem
to have a genetic component like you
know higher rates of certain Cancers and
certain Family Lines or whatever like
yeah as soon as we decode the genome we
will be able to like solve all of that
stuff
hasn't come to fruition because at every
step in the way like biology is way more
complex and and stymies your efforts
harder and more robustly than people
ever assume that it will like and and
yet we keep doing it again and again
yeah and the thing is like it's so
it's so tantalizing right because
because in all of these cases except for
like the vitamin C being a wonder drug
thing but like in all of the other cases
like there there was
there were easy wins to start with yeah
you know like there were the the first
like four or five vitamins that were
discovered did like cure diseases and
absolutely just directly save lives and
it really was that [__] simple and so
like it's not unreasonable to think like
there might be some more easy wins like
this
like with Penicillin like it [__]
worked man like it was incredible uh and
like you know before people before there
were drugs to treat bacteria why would
people even be thinking about like drug
resistance yeah so like think about that
like they must have been like
damn it yeah but yeah so I didn't think
of this like easy win like it seems that
simple the early genetic conditions we
knew about were like
easy genetic like we're talking like
single Gene issues instead of like most
stuff which is massively polygenic
um so yeah there's like biology is a
cruel [__] to researchers where at at
first it just seems like oh man you just
discovered this thing and and it is it
is just so simple like everything else
you've learned about biology to this
point super complex but this time yeah
this time it's different this time it's
easy this time it's simple and that that
just lures people in and then the more
you learn the more you realize like oh
of of the applications of the things
we're learning about two percent of the
applications are simple and then beyond
that it just gets messy as hell again
um
and yeah so I I think that that's like a
common thing that extends up to the
modern day like
even within the last
10 years or so like two other examples
that come to mind which which had like
less broad cultural purchase than say
like Linus Pauling and vitamin C did but
that do still have like purchase amongst
people who
at least had purchase amongst people who
are like pretty serious and pretty well
read
um we're like some anti-aging compounds
so like a few years back like do you
remember how hyped people were about
Resveratrol yes uh yeah like
a lot of that stuff hasn't panned out
like it was supposed to be a wonder drug
that would like improve life lifespan
basically in exercise mimetic in a way
um yeah like yeah it didn't really pan
out
um and a new one that like I don't know
if you've heard of this one have you
heard of nmn no so it's uh nicotinamide
adenine mononucleotide
um
yeah like it's uh it's actually a lot of
the same people who were promoting
Resveratrol before they're like yeah we
may have struck out with resveratrol but
like let's go again yeah like this time
we have it like you take in them in like
it's gonna help you be way healthier
live way longer and like I'll believe it
when I see it you know like there is a
long history of just simple explanations
things seeming like Wonder drugs or
wonder interventions that just just
don't pan out over time
um
and yeah like the the the sorts of
claims like
it does seem like things do are like
gradually becoming like more and more
epistemically grounded like there's it's
less like oh we discover vitamins we
will cure all non-communicable diseases
and now it's more like hey like like
this thing will help like
70 percent of the things that might
break down as you're aging but yeah some
stuff will still go but it is like it's
the same DNA over time yeah and uh yeah
it's it's easy to judge the early
vitamin researchers but I don't think
we've actually come all that far yeah
yeah
um
okay I think that's enough about
vitamins yeah uh move on to minerals
let's do it
so uh minerals they're a bit trickier to
classify than vitamins you don't you
can't just
um you know draw a line say here are the
water soluble ones here are the fat
soluble ones whatever
um
so minerals are all inorganic elements
um rather than organic compounds and we
generally consider something to be a
mineral if it is an element that is
essential for normal health and
development excluding the four major
elements found in organic compounds so
like you know you wouldn't call like
carbon a mineral you wouldn't call
nitrogen a mineral because yeah like we
have this whole thing organic chemistry
that's that's where those things go and
um yeah like like minerals are the
inorganic elements like everything
except for carbon hydrogen oxygen
nitrogen that might be like important
for human health
and so of the remaining elements like
the the non-organic elements
um
we know for sure that some are essential
for uh healthy development good health
and normal function it's like for
example calcium and magnesium like
there's there's not any debate about
that really
um but there is like a surprising amount
of scientific debates about some things
that may or may not be minerals like
they're definitely or inorganic
compounds they definitely do something
in the body but then there's debate
about like are they actually critical
for normal development human human
health Etc so I think like the best
example of this would be uh chromium
so Public Health authorities in the U.S
consider chromium to be an essential
element like they consider it to be a
mineral uh Public Health officials in
Europe do not oh wow um
and I controversial yeah I think I
didn't look into it enough to fully
understand like why there's why there's
disagreement there but yeah they
basically look at the same body of
research the American scientists are
like yeah there's enough to say
chromium's essential the European
scientists say ah I'm not so sure
um and then there are also elements that
like
the body seems to be Adept at handling
and there's like certain there's like
circumstantial evidence to suggest that
maybe they're essential who knows but
like no critical function has been
identified yet and may not be identified
um so I'll talk about that more a little
bit later
but with all of that said there are at
least 15 elements besides the one in the
ones in organic compounds that we know
to be essential for human health those
are sodium magnesium phosphorus sulfur
chlorine potassium calcium manganese
iron Cobalt copper zinc selenium
molybdenum and iodine
and of those 15 only 14 are generally
considered to be minerals uh the the odd
one out in that list is Cobalt because
Cobalt is incorporated into Vitamin B12
vitamin B12 is essential for human
health but if just you yourself consume
Cobalt it's not really going to do much
and you yourself can't synthesize
vitamin B12 so it is an essential
element but not in its mineral form like
not just consuming Cobalt by itself
um but yeah so there there are at least
14 minerals
um but as as previously mentioned uh who
knows maybe there's a 15th maybe
chromium who knows uh hope hopefully the
the guys and gals in the US and Europe
can hash it out and come to a consensus
let's come together yeah and um
then there's also like I mentioned
circumstantial reasons to believe that
other elements
maybe are minerals maybe our essential
elements who knows so is that just like
if you eat them they just like hang out
in your body and researchers are like we
don't know what it's doing it's actually
the opposite okay so
um okay elements that are absolutely
absolutely not essential when you
consume them your your body like I'm
anthropomorphizing like carrier perfect
now but whatever you'll get the point
um when you consume something that's
like definitely not essential your body
just kind of looks at it like what the
[__] going on here like hopefully it
doesn't actually get into your body
hopefully it just kind of goes through
and you excrete it you keep it out it's
good but if it gets into your body like
lead or Mercury for instance
your body's just like what the [__] do I
do with this you know
um it might kind of like sequester it
away in adipose tissues like a lot of
like environmental pollutants that your
body doesn't know what to do yeah I mean
basically like for a lot of stuff like
adipose tissue is just like kind of the
junk drawer like we'll just sequester
that over there
um but there's there's not like a tidy
way to excrete it like when something
gets in your Bot like once it's been
absorbed and you can't poop it out
anymore
um you either need to like metabolize it
to more basic stuff that you can sweat
out exhale or urinate or you just need
to be able to Exhale it uh urinate it or
sweat it out kind of directly like those
are the only way stuff leaves and for
stuff like lead or Mercury like you
can't do that like it gets in your body
and it just [__] chills there
um and so like the the kind of
circumstantial reason to think that some
of those other elements might be
um might be essential did I already list
them I can't remember
the 15 no no the the the
ones kind of in this category that maybe
I don't think I did yeah so the the list
is lithium Boron fluorine uh silicon
Vanadium nickel uh bromine and strontium
so like the the commonality between them
is that basically
if you consume them and absorb them your
your body acts like it knows what to do
with them like there are carrier
proteins that can link up with them like
you can excrete them well like your your
body handles them the way it would
handle other minerals like it it seems
like it knows what to do with them yeah
which may imply on some level that they
are potentially serving important
biological functions but like a lot of
them are are very difficult to study um
so a lot of a lot of like nutrition
research to identify if something is an
essential nutrient or not
um they'll do like depletion repletion
studies where say for instance if you
wanted to find out if if uh vitamin B5
pantothenic acid was essential or not
you would basically put together like
like a soylent-esque product that had
enough calories and macronutrients and
all of the other micronutrients to keep
someone alive but it wouldn't have
vitamin B5 and so you would just give
that to people for I think like the
common the common depletion period is
like two or three weeks or something
like that and then just like see like
does [__] start [__] up
um and then to see what nutrient needs
are once you establish it like hey
people aren't consuming this nutrient
bad stuff is starting to happen you
start gradually titrating the dose back
up and for your group of people you see
like when symptoms start going away and
when they've gone away for either all or
basically all of your subjects you're
like okay like that's the RDA
um I mean the actual like rdas and
recommendations themselves they're based
on like more research than just like one
study but that's kind of how we single
study establishing both whether or not a
nutrient is essential and how much of it
you need to consume like that's a common
research design for that type of
research
um but something like [__] strontium
for instance like it is such a trace
element that like like if if it were
necessary I mean you would be consuming
like two micrograms per day that might
just be like dust that you inhale in the
air so like you can't do a classic
depletion repletions yeah because like
you're you're not con I mean like you
can you can do a depletion repletion
study on something that you need to
consume like 200 micrograms of but if
it's like four micrograms then it's a
completely different ball game you know
like there's no way to ensure that
you're not actually accidentally going
to consume a little bit of it
um
and uh
yeah it's also like it's
another kind of type of research to
establish if something's serving a
critical function or not is just like
binge research it's like hey we've got
substrates we've got enzymes like here
in solution and like if we add whatever
to the solution
um like does it have an effect and like
and like oftentimes it's like you would
you would isolate like the enzymes and
and like molecules they work on like in
in the body itself like try to observe
that somehow like in maybe an intact
cell
and there's there's just like so little
of a lot of these elements that like if
they were doing something they would be
like hard to find in the first place you
know
um
anyway in in most cases like I think
most people believe that like they're
probably not essential and a better like
more accurate explanation for why your
body can handle those elements as if
they were essential
uh there are two potential explanations
one is that like maybe they were
essential uh nutrients for something
that we evolved from and just like the
yeah just like the proteins that would
handle those Pro those uh those other
elements were just preserved by
Evolution like there was no selection
pressure to get rid of right so it's
like yeah maybe one of our distant
ancestors did need to consume silicon
but like we don't but like we still just
have those enzymes in our DNA because
like why not like we have we still have
the genes for [__] gills and we
haven't had gills in a long time
um so like who knows uh so that's one
potential explanation the other one is
just that like
a lot of them are are like chemically
similar like on a molecular level two
things that are essential nutrients
um so for instance strontium is in the
same column of the periodic table as
magnesium and calcium are like it's it's
just below them on the periodic table
um but so things that are in the same
column on the periodic table have like
similar numbers of like valence
electrons like similar like
electronegativity type characteristics
and so yeah it could just be that like
the enzymes that do what they do to
calcium can also like handle strontium
in a similar way because it's a it's a
related element
um and yes I think that's most of it but
it it's basically like there is a list
of other elements that we we can't yet
close the door on completely like
they're probably not essential but
we don't know that for sure and the way
the body handles them like who knows
maybe they are but but probably not
um the exception there though uh kind of
like I was talking about with creatine
before and how nebulous the idea of good
health or normal function is
um
it's like you could make the case for
lithium that it might be a an essential
element or like conditionally essential
um it's like there's pretty decent
evidence that higher levels of lithium
and drinking water are associated with
lower suicide rates and lower rates of
hospital admission for psychiatric
problems
um so there was a meta-analysis
published in 2021 and for suicide rates
in particular there were 14 studies with
a total of 94 million people oh my gosh
um so like
on the surface pretty strong uh it is
worth noting that there was significant
heterogeneity between the studies
included in the meta and there was some
evidence of publication bias but there
is at least like
reasonably decent indication that
um yeah like not not taking enough
lithium to like knock you out like you
know actual like psychiatric medical
doses but like a little bit of lithium
in the in the drinking water seems to
make people a little happier a little
less likely to kill themselves
okay but like you know
how far down that road do you need to go
right before you consider it like good
health normal function because again
like most most aren't going to get
admitted to the hospital for psychiatric
yes most people aren't going to kill
themselves yeah but like we do see like
again I don't want to overstate it
because of the heterogeneity potential
publication bias but there is at least
like indication that like like a little
bit of lithium
seems to help a lot of people do a
little better
um so yeah kind of where do you draw
that line and say like oh this is good
health and normal function but this
isn't like it's
yeah once again like kind of hazy I
think I think there is a discussion that
could be had there
um yeah so long story short with
minerals
um we there we don't actually have a
tidy list of what should be classified
as minerals there are 14 that are
definitely minerals like definitely
essential inorganic elements
um you have you have chromium as like
the strongest maybe of the other
additional like in the U.S it would be a
mineral in Europe it wouldn't be and
then there are eight other like very
more tenuous maybes where yeah I think
maybe you could make a case potentially
for lithium I think maybe you could
potentially make a case for fluorine I
don't think there's much there for like
Silicon or Vanadium or strontium but
like
yeah that doors that doors is cracked to
just like the smallest sliver like I I
don't think anyone is holding their
breath thinking that like Vanadium is
actually a mineral but it's not like
completely ruled out
um and I I mean this is a topic for
another day but um
uh one of the other ones on the list was
Boron and there are a lot of uh a lot of
people in Tick Tock these days thinking
Boron is oh really good for you the
people drinking borax I've heard of that
yeah um but yeah that is a conversation
for another day
so yeah I think
uh oh oh uh and just like the last thing
to say about minerals is much like
um much like fat soluble vitamins like I
mentioned before like it it is hard to
just categorize them it's just like oh
minerals do X like it's it's not like
water soluble vitamins where they're all
coenzymes or cofactors they do a variety
of different things so like calcium
straightforward helps maintain bone
health also helps with like muscle
contractility like timing of heart
contraction stuff like that
um sodium and potassium are primarily
necessary for helping maintain the
bioelectrical potential across uh
membranes of cells to help with like
nerve conduction and and skeletal muscle
contraction like responding to the the
neural stimuli they get chlorine doesn't
do a heck of a lot but what it does do
is extremely important uh you need to
consume chlorine so your body can make
hydrochloric acid for your stomach like
to help with digestion
um
iron is important because it's a
component of hemoglobin and myoglobin
which your body uses to transport oxygen
other minerals also just function as
cofactors
um
selenium I'll talk about selenium more
in a later episode but it's wild like
it's it's incorporated into these
proteins called seleno proteins that do
like a bunch of crazy [__] and
um
so Lenny no no one [__] thinks about
selenium but as as I was doing reading
on this stuff I think selenium is my
favorite nutrient now just because
there's a lot of like there's a lot of
weird [__] about it it was fun
um yeah I think I think that's good for
minerals Okay so we've done vitamins
we've done minerals how about essential
fatty acids all right so
the name themselves tell you what it is
they're they're fatty acids and they're
essential they're essential they're
necessary for normal health and function
your body can't make them itself though
so you need to get them from your diet
um
and uh yeah so they're
um all of the essential fatty acids are
either classified as omega-3 or omega-6
fats and well I think we'll talk about
them more in a later episode as well but
they they have a wide variety of
functions in the body but are primarily
implicated in regulating and influencing
Pro and anti-inflammatory processes
um there's been a lot of scare mongering
about omega-6 fats like if you've heard
people uh talking about like seed oils
and like fear-mongering about that yeah
it's mostly about linoleic acid like the
okay omega-6 that is an essential fatty
acid
um yeah we might talk about that in in a
later episode
um yeah there's not too much more to say
about them but I was wondering do you
know what the Omega means in omega-3
omega-6 no
um so yeah it's a
yeah people talk about omega-3 and
omega-6 fats and I don't think they know
what they're talking about most of the
time
um you don't know what that word means
but it's it's just like a weird little
scientific naming convention like so you
know from you know from the Bible when
God says I am the Alpha and the Omega
the the beginning and end yeah he says
that um so that's it's like that usage
of Omega which like I don't I don't know
why you know what I don't know the Greek
alphabet I'm I'm probably going to [__]
this up and pack is going to message me
and be like you're an idiot you don't
know the Greek alphabet but think Zeta
is is their last letter
but it's it seems like it would be yeah
but it's uh yeah so like
Omega is sometimes used to denote like
finality kind of the Alpha and the Omega
the the beginning and then like that
that's the implication there
but yeah I think Zeta is the last letter
so I don't I don't know where Omega got
that connotation from but it doesn't
matter
um so
omega-3 omega-6 is basically talking
about counting back carbons from the end
of the carbon backbone of the fatty acid
so fats basically have like long
straight ish carbon backbones they might
have little bins if it's an unsaturated
fat but basically you just have carbon
bonded to carbon bonded to carbon and
there and those carbons are also bonded
to uh hydrogen molecules like coming off
of that carbon backbone and
when a pair of carbons is like a pair of
carbons that are next to each other are
only bound to one hydrogen instead of
two that basically means they have an
additional valence electron they can
form an additional bond with so instead
of a single bond to the next carbon
it'll form a double bond with the next
carbon which causes a little a little
kink in that chain and
um an omega-3 fat is if you go from the
start of the fat chain all the way to
the bottom so like the the top end is
what would be bound to the the glycerol
like if it was a triglyceride like
that's the start and then the end is
basically the the tail like the carbon
furthest away from the one that would be
bound to the glycerol
um so that that is the Omega carbon and
so you basically just count back three
bonds from there and if that is a double
bond like a point of unsaturation then
it's an omega-3 fat if you count back
six and there's a bin there then it's um
I see and basically like there is
like a single specific enzyme so like
your body has enzymes that can convert
saturated fat to unsaturated fat at
various places but like you need a like
enzymes are hyper specific a lot of a
lot of the times and so like you need a
specific enzyme to cause a desaturation
at that like third position or at that
sixth position that an enzyme that can
desaturate a carbon at the ninth
position like wouldn't it be able to do
yeah
um so yeah like we we just don't have
the enzymes to desaturate that like
third Omega position Bond
um oh okay and yeah so that's why it's
essential okay yeah
um
yeah okay I'm gonna move on essential
amino acids
yeah I think most people listening to
this podcast this will be old hat amino
acids are the building blocks of protein
um and essential amino acids are the
ones that you can't produce on your own
meaning you have to consume them from
your food of the 20 amino acids that
your body uses to build most proteins
nine are considered to be essential
those are histidine isoleucine leucine
lysine methionine phenylalanine
threonine tryptophan and valine and
there are six other amino acids that are
considered conditionally essential
mentioned that earlier in the episode
but essentially means your body can
usually synthesize them in sufficient
quantities if you didn't consume them
from your diet but there are situations
where you may not be able to synthesize
them in sufficient quantities in which
case they would become essential and
those conditionally essential ones are
Arginine cysteine glutamine tyrosine
Glycine and Proline
um
and yeah there's not too much more to
say about that basically if you don't
consume enough of an essential amino
acid like bad [__] can happen
um realistically the ones you need to
worry about like if
realistically most people listening to
this don't need to worry about it at all
nice
um like it really only becomes an issue
if just like overall protein intake is
really low which this is a fitness
podcast a lot of people listening to
this consume the shitload yeah
absolutely not
um so yeah if if total protein intake is
really low or if you're just a vegan and
a very picky eater and don't like
consuming any of the number of like
great complete protein like vegan
protein sources like soy micro protein
like they're they're plenty quinoa
um and you know like if if you just only
liked rice
um like rice is really low in lysine so
like you could have a lysine deficiency
uh but yeah like lysine methionine and
tryptophan are really the only ones that
most people would need to worry about
lysine if you just are a vegan and just
really [__] like cereal grains and
you don't like beans
um or like soy or anything else uh
methionine if you just really like beans
and uh legumes and pulses and don't
really like anything else
um and tryptophan if you're just a big
corn head and don't corn yeah yeah like
um yeah so so most
diseases resulting from essential amino
acid deficiencies
you mostly only see it in the developing
world where there is just like a staple
crop that like 90 of your calories come
from
um and even then it's still like
relatively uncommon because even if 90
of your calories are coming from Rice
like ah you eat some soybeans from time
to time or maybe like a splash of milk
and like that's usually sufficient yeah
um you know maybe not to like maximize
hypertrophy but just to prevent diseases
that would result from like an actual
deficiency in an in an essential amino
acid so yeah like it's um
yeah it's one of those things to be
aware of but I think that
like I mean I don't think we're
particularly biased here like we we are
both omnivores yes um but you know you
know so we're not just trying to like
carry water for for vegan nutrition but
like
do you think a lot of omnivores who
maybe like don't like the idea of
veganism for
uh either for reasons that they're not
fully aware of themselves or for reasons
that they wouldn't want to articulate to
a vegan will Express that concern as
like oh where are you gonna get your
protein what about like essential amino
acid deficiencies and like
but you bait you basically never need to
worry about that like even if you're a
vegan if you consume a varied diet
um and like if you really like rice
maybe sometimes have some beans or like
sometimes consume soy products like it's
gonna be fine yeah
um
okay the last three little weird ones we
have choline fiber and water
choline it exists in a state of limbo it
is like basically a vitamin and like I
mentioned before it used to be a vitamin
it used to be vitamin B4 yeah
um but medical and scientific
organizations haven't like reclassified
it as a vitamin again probably because
like at this point there is kind of a
convention for the water-soluble
vitamins like they're all coenzymes or
cofactors choline isn't
um like it does other stuff uh but yeah
your your body can produce choline in
your liver but it doesn't produce enough
for like the best possible Health
outcomes much like niacin
um and so yeah it doesn't neatly fit
into any of the other categories of
essential nutrients like vitamins
minerals essential fatty acids essential
amino acids but it is still an essential
nutrient that's just kind of like
hanging out in its own category
um choline is used to produce a couple
uh phospholipids that help preserve the
structural Integrity of cell membranes
and it's also uh like an important
component of acetylcholine which is one
of your body's most abundant
neurotransmitters
um and yeah like used to be considered a
vitamin then it was kicked off the list
and then as of 1998 it was it was
re-established as an essential nutrient
which
I do think
um is good to know like 1998 wasn't that
long ago yeah and most of the things
related to vitamins were
yeah like there was that like mad mad
rush uh in the 35 years after the first
vitamins were discovered but like it is
still an active topic of of concern in
research like
within the lifetimes of most of the
people listening to this a new essential
nutrient was added in the form of
choline which is fun
um moving on to fiber
so fiber is not actually uh
traditionally considered an essential
nutrient by
um like scientific bodies uh and like
public health sources which I do also
think again like speaks to the haziness
of the definition of an essential
nutrient because
uh it's not like if you don't consume
fiber you'll die like you'll be fine
like you can live without ever consuming
fiber but it does also it it will likely
increase your risk of like colon cancer
and so it's like hey what how do we
Define normal health and good function
is it like going through life with a
five percent rate of colon cancer or
like a 15 rate of colon cancer like you
know does that shift in Risk uh change
how you think about Good Health normal
function yeah again philosophical
question for other people to deal with
um but I I did want to talk about it uh
in this episode and also in the series
just because like
iifym people like and I assume most
people listening to this know that
acronym but that is If It Fits your
Macros
um people who mostly or almost entirely
just pay attention to uh total calorie
intake and macronutrients like uh
protein carbs and fat
um a lot of them will say like oh yeah
but like you also need to consume enough
fiber that is kind of like the one bone
towards towards like macros not
necessarily being everything like yeah I
eat some Fiber too so I did want to talk
about fiber a little bit
um but I did I did notice something that
was kind of funny that I I assume was
just like an error that an editor missed
but
um yeah like fiber is not generally
considered an essential nutrient because
yeah you can you can live without fiber
your whole life
um
but uh like a and d The Academy of
nutrition and dietetics like the people
who license dietitians in the U.S
um I I found a journal article uh from
them from like 2015 2016 that just like
categorically says Fiverr is not an
essential nutrient and then I found an
article on their website
um published like five years after that
journal article that starts with the
line fibrin is an essential nutrient and
whoa and like I think the article is
just wrong like at least at least in
terms of communicating uh and D's
standard yes
um but I did find that kind of funny
just like very categorical statements
from the same organization saying
completely different stuff yeah um yeah
what like like I said I just I just
found that funny I assume it's just a
flub though I think it's funny because
it speaks to kind of the haziness of
this like even on their website you're
like what the [__] I don't is it
essential or not yeah they don't know I
don't know yeah for sure
um yeah so fiber is a broad class of
indigestible carbohydrates
so like most of the carbohydrates you
would consume would be starches which
are just long chains of sugar molecules
that are that are bonded together
um and fiber is the same way it is also
like it's a carbohydrate it's it's
composed of sugar molecules that are
bonded together much like starch so what
is the difference between starch and
fiber do you know or did you know before
looking at the outline I don't know oh
okay
um so yeah it basically the raw material
is the same but uh like I was talking
about before with how like
hyper-specific enzymes are the primary
difference between most start or most
fibers and starches is just the type of
bonds between the sugar molecules okay
so in starches
um like a uh amylose for instance like
most basic starch you don't need to know
what that is it's fine whatever
um but it's just composed of glucose
molecules that are bonded together uh by
Alpha glycosidic bonds and like you
don't need to know what the alpha means
but it's basically just a description of
how the the bonds are already like the
bond is oriented relative to like the
two glucose like the two glucose
molecules that are next to each other
um so yeah it's bonded together with an
alpha glycosidic Bond versus cellulose
which is I think the most common type of
fiber we consume it's the primary
structural component of plant cell walls
um
it is exactly the same as amylose it is
also just a long string of glucose
molecules bonded together
um but instead of
it being Alpha glycosidic bonds it is
beta glycosidic bonds which
same like it's even still like covalent
bonds like it's the same type of bond
it's the same molecules but just like
the orientation of it is a little bit
different and so it's a beta glycosidic
Bond instead of Alpha and we have
enzymes that can break down Alpha
glycosidic bonds so we can digest
amylose just fine and uh we can't digest
cellulose at all can't even make a dent
in it okay because we just don't have
that that correct enzyme
um
and yeah like that's that is the main
difference
um so yeah the difference between like
like a a tree and a potato you have
similar carbohydrate content but the
reason we can eat and digest a potato
and not a tree is that just the the type
of bonds between the the glucose
molecules which I think is fun
um so there are
three fun little facts I have about
fiber okay one of them might be a fake
fact but we'll see what that's not a
fact then and if it's fake I'll also
give you the real one
um okay okay so number one
is by and large the enzymes that we
produce to break down and digest
carbohydrate uh are enzymes that break
down Alpha glycosidic bonds not beta
glycosidic bonds like I was saying
before and the most notable exception to
that is the enzyme lactase which is what
breaks down lactose yes um so yeah
lactose is a disaccharide like it's
composed of two sugar molecules it's a
galactose and a glucose molecule bonded
together with a beta-glycosidic bond and
that could that like May potentially at
least partially explain why lactose
intolerance is fairly common just
because like lactase itself is a weird
enzyme yeah like we don't produce much
of that type of enzyme like an enzyme to
break a beta glycosidic Bond it's weird
like we just don't do that
um so I think that's cool that is a
potential partial explanation for for
why like lactose intolerance is
relatively common but like starch
intolerance isn't
um
the one that might be fake news
is so okay
the conventional explanation for where
coal came from uh like like you know
charcoal right you burn it get
electricity
um the conventional explanation for that
also relates to how hard it is to break
beta glycosidic bonds Okay so
the the conventional explanation is that
large plants produce a particular type
of fiber called lignin and uh the like
plants evolved with the ability to
produce lignin before
um the fungus that is predominantly
responsible for breaking down lignant in
dead plants before it evolved so like
there are like some little
microorganisms that can break down
lignin but in terms of just being able
to break down a shitload of it
relatively quickly there is like a
particular like fungus that does most of
that the world over or not like one
single speed but like kind of a class of
fungi that do that
um and so like there is some like fossil
evidence which is like kind of Up For
Debate because like fungi don't
fossilize that often or that readily but
there there is like some evidence that
plants evolve the ability to produce
lignin before the particular type of
fungus that breaks down lignin now
before it evolved the ability to do so
by like
uh you know
couple million years
um and so basically during that
interregnum during that intervening
period plants grew they died like trees
fell down whatever and like some of it
could be broken down but like the lignin
like a large portion of its carbohydrate
content was just completely like nothing
could break it down it just [__]
chilled there forever and so uh over
time like
kind of dead trees accumulated they got
buried by soil pressure blah blah blah
whatever you get charcoal
um and so like part of the evidence for
that is that like
coal does all seem to be like kind of
around the same age
um like we when we
I don't know I don't know when people
think like the the time of dispersal of
like fossil fuels was like hey was were
we were we making oil in the Cretaceous
Period or just the Triassic like I don't
know if people are thinking more
considering that like I think that
sometimes I don't know that isn't
surprised I just kind of assumed that
there were like hundreds of millions of
years or billions of years that like
coal was forming right now but like
in in geologic terms like most of the
coals seem to have been laid down in a
pretty like pretty thin like rock strata
like okay
um it seems to all be locatable within
like a relic like a [__] long period
of time like in geologic terms a pretty
short period of time
um and yeah like there there is that
evidence that like yeah maybe fungi
didn't have this ability yet and so that
that has been like the conventional
explanation for like where did the coal
come from why did it all seem to be
deposited in about the same period of
time uh for a long long time basically
you couldn't break down the plants they
built up they were buried that all
became cold
um there is an alternate explanation
that I so I do do additional research
for this podcast like I I don't just I
don't just repeat stuff that I that I
like read for other purposes and like I
was thinking about it I I was like that
feels like a bit too much of a just so
story let me read about this a little
bit more
um and so as of like 2016 I believe
there is a different hypothesis uh for
it that I I think has pretty wide
purchase now so like that this this I
think is currently believed to be the
more correct explanation
um which is it was basically just a
a ideal Confluence of events as the
super continent of Pangea was coming
together just like all of that tectonic
activity with like what was previously
in Ocean now being surrounded by like
land masses coming together it just
created like a bunch of marshes that are
like ideal for kind of peat and then
coal to form because it's like really
oxygen poor so like if something dies
and it sinks down in the swamp it can be
like covered and just like not exposed
to like fungi or bacteria that could
break it down and so like um
yeah like like there are still peat
marshes today where the stuff you know
is not as old as
uh like coal or oil or whatever
um so yeah like that that is the current
the current leading hypothesis I think
it's just like uh pangeo is coming
together it just made like really good
marshes for for uh for coal to well for
initially peat to form and then it gets
buried pressure heat whatever becomes
cold
so anyway I do I do like the old
explanation better that's just a bunch
of dead trees just piled up for millions
of years and eventually became charcoal
before fungi figured out how to break
down lignin but
whatever anyway so that's a fun probably
not fact and the breaking down lignin is
our is our connection to fiber yeah yeah
because beta glycosidic bonds yeah not
much can break it down very strong
okay uh third third fun fact is that
um not all fiber uh is actually
indigestible and in fiber because of the
types of bonds so you can actually get
fiber from starch itself
so there's a a class of compounds called
resistant starch and they're like
different kinds of resistant starch but
it's not worth talking about the
differences here
um which which is just starch like it's
amylose amylopectin like the the normal
[__] that would be in like rice potatoes
bread whatever
um
but it is considered resistant because
it resists digestion but not because of
the types of bonds but just basically
due to like shape so if the starches are
exposed the enzymes can get in they can
break down the bonds then you get the
little sugar molecules they get into
your bloodstream your body knows what to
do with them but with resistant starch
essentially either if if starchy things
are uncooked or if they're cooked and
then cooled down again
instead of just kind of continuing to be
exposed they'll either be like
pre-existing in crystalline structures
or they will reform crystalline
structures when cooled and that
basically like protects a lot of the
starch inside because
you know theoretically if resistance
starts just hung out in your small
intestine for like months like you would
probably be able to digest it completely
but just in the time frame on which
digestion takes place it just it just
can't do it like it basically curls up
in like a little crystalline cocoon so
that it's not exposed to the enzymes and
um yeah then it behaves like a fiber
like you you can't digest it uh it might
get to your large intestine where like
some bacteria can break it down but
like it's it's starch but it behaves
like a fiber and it used to be
considered kind of its own thing like
people would talk about starch and fiber
and kind of resistant starch as this
whole separate thing that's just kind of
between the two but more and more often
in in recent years I see like scientists
and researchers just referring to
resistant starch as a type of fiber
which is fun so it's it's not all just
about the bonds sometimes it's about the
shape and crystalline structures and we
like crystals on this podcast I guess I
don't know I feel neutral about them
actually I don't I'm not like woo-woo
about crystals but I do [__] love
crystals like I think we love a crystal
shop yeah yeah like I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna like purchase stuff and be
like oh yes well you did in Atlanta well
that was that was a ball of copper
though it wasn't a Christmas it was in a
crystal shop yeah but so dear listeners
I bought a ball of copper and it's one
of the best purchases I've ever made
um it is so satisfying to have something
that's like it's probably like an inch
in diameter but it's so much heavier
than most things are smaller than a golf
ball yeah but it's it's just it has so
much more heft than something that is
approximately that size and just a
little thing that's kind of heavy like
it's not and it's shiny it's cool I love
I love messing with it it's one of the
most fun things to fidget with
um
anyway it's good but we're not Crystal
people we're not no but if you aren't
that's fine that's cool it is okay so
last thing about fiber there are
probably two types soluble and insoluble
insoluble fiber is stuff that both you
and your gut bacteria can't digest you
eat it and it basically gets through
your digestive system
essentially unscathed you poop it out it
helps with gastric motility by kind of
like kind of like irritating the walls
of your intestines and then they're like
no [__] you get out of here so it'll so
yeah so yeah they'll do more peristalsis
to get this noxious irritating thing out
like that that's largely how it
increases gastric motility I don't know
what to tell you like you're you're I
mean it's gross but that's correct yeah
yeah uh also helps add bulk to feces so
it helps you stay regular so if if
people are like I'm taking fiber to help
me poop like it's probably it's probably
insoluble fiber yeah
um and then soluble fiber you can't
digest it but your gut bacteria can
um largely like not always but typically
um so you ferment it in your large
intestine and so like if you get gassy
after eating fiber it's probably from
soluble fiber rather than insoluble like
the gas is created by your intestinal
bacteria breaking down the soluble fiber
and as it does so it does it might make
you gassy but it's those bacteria are
also producing various compounds that
help keep your colon healthy and reduce
your risk of colon cancer and some of
those compounds are short chain fatty
acids
which are still absorbed through the
lining of your large intestine that your
body can use for energy so
even though you yourself aren't directly
digesting soluble fiber you you do still
derive some energy from it like an
average of about two calories per gram
versus like just straight up zero for
for insoluble fiber what are some
examples of foods in both categories
oh God you're putting me on the spot I'm
sorry
um
let's see for for insoluble fiber like
one of I think one of the classic
examples is oatmeal I think it's like 50
50 soluble insoluble
um
for insoluble fiber like
anything that's like just really fibrous
would would have it like
I'm I don't know this to be the case but
I'm going to guess that like the kind of
like strings and celery I'm going to
guess that those are insoluble fibers
um I think a lot of the fibers or a lot
of the fiber that is present in just
like
green leafy vegetables like in kale or
whatever like I think a lot of that is
insoluble
I'll be honest I don't know for sure
though like not just right off the top
of my head because I I don't care that
much like I
when it comes to fiber my basic approach
is just like eat some fruits and
vegetables sometimes and I assume
whatever I'm getting will be fine yeah
um but yeah yeah okay
last one water not gonna say too much
about it just that when people talk
about essential nutrients water is often
overlooked
but it's it's maybe by some definitions
maybe the most important of them all
seems like um you need to consume more
of it than any other nutrient you need
to consume and uh not consuming it will
kill you faster than any other nutrient
like all of the other essential
nutrients if you never consume them you
will die except for vitamin D again I
don't know that you'll never die I I
think it might be conditionally
essential whatever uh hot take but water
absolutely [__] essential and um yeah
don't consume vitamin B1 you'll you'll
die of berry berry in months I guess
don't consume water like you're dead in
a week so very important absolutely an
essential nutrient don't sleep on the
water
unless you have a waterbed yes yes or uh
or if you're an otter
oh man if there are any otters listening
to this podcast shouts to you now I'm
thinking about
otters that they sleep with their
partner and they hold hands so they
don't drift away in the tide it's so
cute they are very cute creatures I love
otters I think I think we're done
talking about micronutrients for today I
think we are do you uh do you have any
questions or anything you want to add
just general thoughts about
micronutrients
just that I'm excited for the future
episodes
good I am too
nice
all right so we have a question about
bone health
hi my name is Monica and I would like to
know
in what way
uh training for optimal bone health
would differ from training for muscle
strength and hypertrophy if at all
um
my guess is that pushing exercises would
be better than pulling I've also heard
that Plyometrics are best
uh
are plyometrics safe for people over 60.
thank you all right thank you for that
question uh and that that is a very good
question so by and large training you
would do to build muscle and strength
will also be good for
um building bone strength as well or
preserving bone strength into older age
but there are the the main difference is
that there are things that you could do
for bone health that wouldn't
necessarily be ideal training for
strength and muscle but for the most
part if you are primarily training to
build strength or build muscle you
probably don't necessarily need to worry
too much about doing additional training
for bone health but
um to the extent that those differences
exist uh one of the things you mentioned
was Plyometrics plyometric training if
you're untrained will probably help
build some muscle but if if you're
reasonably well trained it's probably
not going to be a great hypertrophy
stimulus but it does cause pretty high
forces on the bones it probably would be
a pretty decent stimulus for bone
remodeling and another good example is
just the types of like cardio you might
want to do so
um like jogging or running for instance
because of the impact element of it
um it's also just good for bone health
compared to lower impact forms of cardio
like cycling or swimming or rowing
um
and so like by and large uh none of
those things are going to be
particularly productive for building
muscle or getting stronger but yeah if
you wanted to run instead of do those
other things it's probably a little bit
better for bone health
um but overall
if you're if you are already training
for muscle and strength you're you're
probably covered on the bone health
front
um
so before I say kind of the main thing I
want to say I do just want to address
the question about Plyometrics being
like the best stimulus for bone
remodeling and whether that still
applies in your 60s or whether plyos are
still safe in your 60s
um
so bone remodeling is kind of weird
where
it basically and like this is still like
a developing area of research so
everything I'm about to say may be found
to be wrong in like five years but this
is this is the current understanding of
of people that study this stuff it seems
like there's essentially a maximum
stimulus that that your bones can kind
of like sense and respond to and once
you exceed that level of stimulus in a
particular session
um it just doesn't really do much else
like you you've already achieved a
maximum stimulus for bone remodeling and
so Plyometrics do cause like really high
like acute impact forces so you you do
get like large like really acute
compressive forces on on your bones and
so like on a contraction by contraction
basis doing Plyometrics might like put
more force on your femur and therefore
cause a greater remodeling response than
say like a single rep of squats would so
just kind of like on a on a rip by rep
basis
I wouldn't be surprised if you do if you
did get the largest stimulus from
Plyometrics but
um since there is kind of that cap going
on since you do kind of hit that Plateau
Beyond which further stimulus just
doesn't really seem to further increase
bone remodeling
um you like
I think you can probably reach the same
total like dosage of stimulus for a
workout from resistance training or
Plyometrics such that like you know the
idea that Plyometrics being the best
stimulus there is like I think that I
think that that's probably true but also
not all that applicable like if if you
were just doing three reps and that was
your entire workout yeah maybe do
Plyometrics if you're just doing a whole
workout I I think it probably doesn't
matter all that much
um
and then the question about oh uh safety
uh so whether or not Plyometrics are
safe I think is less of an age question
and more of a are your tissues prepared
for it question so if uh in general like
connective tissue does tend to get
weaker with age so like you you might
have a slightly elevated risk of some
sort of tendon or ligament injury if you
do Plyometrics but in general it's it's
mostly a question of just kind of like
what are your tissues adapted to and
capable of and with most things
it'll be fine if you ease into it so if
you took someone who was just completely
deconditioned at 20 and completely
deconditioned at 60 and said hey we're
going to put you through a really tough
plyometric workout I think there's I
think there's a very good chance that
the 60 year old would be much more
likely to get injured than the 20 year
old but if you took someone who had
already been doing plyometric training
like their whole life and now they're 60
years old it's probably perfectly fine
or if you haven't done Plyometrics but
you you just want to for whatever reason
I think you could probably work with a
trainer to gradually build up to that
where instead of say doing like 18 inch
depth of jumps and like trying to you
know hit hard jump high like all of that
like really really high reactive forces
you know just starting with like a three
inch step down from a box where you just
step off absorb the force boom that's it
and just really really basic stuff and
build from there I think you probably
could do Plyometrics like plyometric
type exercise safely at just about any
age it's just a question of whether or
not you give your tissues enough time to
look to adapt to that type of loading
um but then the last and I think the
main thing I wanted to say about
training for bone health
is just that like resistance training
itself is fine and probably more than
sufficient for most people most of the
time so
um in in the question uh Monica said
that she
assumed that uh pushing exercises are
probably better than pulling exercises
and I think the Assumption underpinning
that is it is a reasonable assumption
people have when they think about like
forces on on your bones and bone
remodeling with lifting but is is
actually like not a great assumption so
that assumption is I I think and and
Monica if you weren't thinking this I
apologize but I think a lot of people
look at look at the forces on your body
and lifting and mostly only account for
external forces and so like with a
pressing exercise for instance like
bench press the bar is is resting in
your outstretched arms and the weight of
the bar is pressing into your hands so
that is putting compressive forces on
your bones versus like a row for
instance like it's the same basic motor
pattern but in Reverse but now you know
the weight is like pulling out so like
it's not putting the same compressive
force on your bone and so U.S assume
that like ah this is probably a worse
stimulus than than the pressing exercise
would be and like in the stronger by
science Facebook group there was a
question about this related to like
squats versus knee extensions like with
the assumption that since the weight is
like over your body in squats like it's
it's pressing down causing compressive
forces all the way through your body to
the floor versus knee extension like
maybe it's causing some shearing forces
but the weight isn't oriented along the
long axis of your of your femur or tibia
so like it wouldn't be putting
compressive forces on anything so like
it wouldn't be doing much for bone
remodeling so the the basic
um
like the the basic bit of information
about all of this stuff that like folks
very very frequently Overlook is that
most of the forces your muscles are
experiencing is not from the load your
lifting it's from your actual like
muscle contractions themselves
hey just recording a quick correction in
post uh I meant to say that most of the
forces your bones experience are the
result of muscle contractions sorry now
back to the episode
and I I always say this anytime this
comes up because it blows people's minds
but it's completely true
your muscles are so [__] strong like
you people people don't realize this
your muscles are so [__] strong so
for instance let's say your your one rep
max bicep curl with one arm is 10 pounds
like not much weight at all it seems
like Podunk nothing like ah man I'm so
weak I can only curl 10 pounds
your your biceps
are probably Contracting with around 100
pounds of force so like your your body
has a very inefficient lever system like
a very efficient lever system for like
flexibility but really inefficient for
for moving large external loads so if
you think about where your bicep inserts
on your forearm it's very very close to
your elbow uh versus your hand pretty
far away from your elbow so like the
distance from where the load is to the
axis of rotation for the joint is
probably about 10 times greater than the
distance from where your muscle inserts
to the axis of rotation for the joint
which means that if you have 10 pounds
in your hands due to where your bicep is
inserting like it would need to contract
with a hundred pounds of force in order
to move 10 pounds so like that that
scales like if if you're doing knee
extensions with 50 pounds like that's
like the same general principle would
apply like with
um with like quad contractions like if
you're doing knee extensions with 50
pounds like that's that's not all that
much weight but your quads are probably
Contracting with like four or five
hundred pounds of force just like linear
force and most of your muscles are
oriented along the long axis of Bones
um like like of of the joints they cross
and so if your biceps are Contracting
with a hundred pounds of force if you're
just lifting 10 pounds that means you're
putting about a hundred pounds of
compressive force on your humerus if
you're just doing knee extensions with
50 pounds like you're you're putting
about four or five hundred pounds of
compressive force on your femur just
from your quads Contracting
um and so that that is where most of the
force comes from and so
um yeah like a pressing exercise there
is also the additional external load of
the bar but the the additional external
load is so small compared to the forces
your your muscles themselves are
generating
um that like yeah it it is probably
technically true that the that the
forces on your bones are a little bit
higher in pressing than pulling
exercises but not enough to worry about
because the the external load is almost
irrelevant
um just because your muscles are
Contracting with so much force and most
of the force here bones themselves are
feeling is the force generated by your
muscles Contracting
um and yeah it's it's a shitload of
force and so uh if you're doing pretty
challenging resistance training that
should be a more than sufficient
stimulus for bone remodeling and if
you're younger increasing bone strength
if you're older preserving bone strength
uh into your golden years
and uh so yeah there there there are
some stimuli that are on the table for
bone health that wouldn't necessarily
apply for building muscle and strength
like plyos like running instead of
cycling or swimming like you can have
like a slightly bigger tool kit but if
you're already doing resistance training
you you probably just don't need to
worry about it too much because
resistance training itself is such a
good stimulus because your muscles are
so strong they're putting very large
forces on your bones
okay uh that is it for this episode uh
thanks for listening we'll talk to you
again in two weeks with part two of this
series which I'm thinking
at this moment will probably be a
three-parter but we'll see
um
until then eat your fruits and veggies
have a good couple of weeks uh we love
you we appreciate you and we'll talk to
you again next time goodbye bye